This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Christina.
Right.
Dolla
finally.
So it's hard.
I like it a lot.
Shit,
Shit.
I've taken a shit homie.
Yo,
check it out.
Got It.
Feels like I've been the head of borrowed dates coming up,
Bruh.
I'm the seventh and eighth and tamp are sold out.
I have a few tickets left.
March 9th at the Seminal Hard Rock Hollywood,
Florida,
otherwise known as the semen whole hard cock come Cno in Fort Lauderdale,
Florida.
But for these purposes it's in Hollywood,
A big room.
See tickets left if you want to get them later on in March.
I have two shows in Portland,
Maine.
There are very few tickets left.
March 26 March 27th is sold out.
Uh,
then Red Bank,
New Jersey,
Westbury.
Oh,
new haven,
Connecticut.
March 30th the early show is sold out.
The late show in new haven has a few tickets left.
That is March 30th.
Uh,
late show has tickets in Madison,
Wisconsin.
April 11th.
Late show in Milwaukee.
Has Tickets,
uh,
April 12th and late show in Nashville,
April 14th all at Tom's,
gretta.com/tour a bunch of new shows will be added and announced in April.
If you want first dibs on those tickets,
go to Thomson [inaudible] dot com slash tour and sign up for the email mailing
list that goes out to everyone before the venue presales and before the general
on sale.
And you can get tickets first.
Uh,
g Oh my God.
I just thought it the best one for Milwaukee.
Yeah.
Dick milk,
walkie deck milk walks.
What do you think?
Really good.
It will be on my exit.
Yup.
He smiled.
All right.
Genes are ride or die.
Tour continues.
April four through six mini apple tits.
The acne come
on.
Your comedy clubs.
May 10th and 11th and Tempe,
Arizona at the Tempe and Prague May 31st through June 1st sperm bank,
California Flippers,
comedy club that's here in Burbank and then June 20th through 22nd Washington
did come at the Dick come Improv a tickets at Christina Pete Online.
Also,
if you're not aware,
I know a lot of you are new to this show.
I have to Netflix specials.
One is called mother inferior and a one I had a half hour on a special called
the degenerates with Joey Diaz.
Big Jay Oakerson,
Liza Trager,
who's been on a guest on this show and Yamaneika Saunders.
So try it out.
Check it out under Christina P.
My name is just Christina.
Yes.
What's up?
Thank you.
That's it,
right?
Uh,
yeah.
All right guys,
if you do your shopping,
uh,
on Amazon,
use our banner,
your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Click on the banner at the bottom of the homepage.
Do Your shopping as you normally would.
Bookmark it.
Thank you.
Um,
we're about to get this show started.
There's a lot.
Talk about we have great guests coming in.
Are you ready?
Let's do it.
Well,
I don't like Facebook and I don't like the Internet because I can't find a job.
The library blocked my password.
Now me.
Does that make any sense to you?
No.
Bring it
to your mom's house,
Christina.
Okay.
Japan.
How does the library block your password?
Oh,
this is a really good one.
Yeah.
You're,
you're really gonna enjoy this by the way.
I,
uh,
I'm being told that that opening audio instrumental was ob one that was an ob.
Whoa.
Right.
Rental.
I see one that's the old school.
A Mahalo.
Oh,
be one cannoli.
Yup.
Um,
but back to my point,
how does the library,
I'm sorry,
the library block ones pass.
Well,
I think you need to get the first,
cause I,
I have a little experience with this,
uh,
ladies,
don't you?
This lady,
by the way,
for people listening is going up to a town hall hearing.
We're about an issue of where basically,
you know,
there's the,
the people that have power,
right?
The city commissioners and whatever their titles are,
and then there's an audience of members of the public and then you kind of can
take your turn to walk up to the mic and address the issue at hand.
Yeah.
So,
yeah,
go ahead.
Just,
I'm very excited because I have a very good observation.
Yeah.
Um,
the,
the rock quality.
Yeah.
Is that what you're going to go to?
Yeah,
really.
I think the common denominator with a really great why I'm h Lady Club,
we've already determined what the guys are who are Bra quality.
No Bra,
no Bra,
and the biggest sloppers you've ever seen.
Yeah,
and they're not young slobbers like they've got to be 40 plus.
Oh yeah,
no,
they got some miles on him and then she's got like the ridiculous chain around
her neck.
Oh yeah,
like keys.
Yeah.
It's like a key card.
It's an official thing.
Like a laminate.
It's your qualifications.
Her life calls.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Let's see.
Oh fuck.
Hello.
The glasses.
My name is Lisa.
And why Whitner Wagman Ooh,
I just moved here because I'm getting a divorce and it's not final till
September 18th my husband will not give me any money.
Not One penny.
The lawyer won't help me.
My husband won't help me.
Sure.
My Dad,
Marlin Leigh Widmer,
he's a minister.
Won't help me.
Yeah.
My step mother won't help me.
My mother passed away seven years ago.
Ma'Am,
we're discussing the rezoning for the Portello's DMA comments on that for what
we're discussing.
The rezoning.
Third four well,
I live on 63rd again,
we're here to hear comments about the rezoning.
Well,
I don't like Facebook.
Okay.
And I don't like the Internet because I can't find a job.
The library blocked my password.
Now tell me,
does that make any sense to you?
No,
it actually does.
When I think that the library,
I believe the library may have issues with her.
I think she probably earned that block.
Yeah.
They blocked her password.
Tom,
how do they block your password?
I don't know.
It makes no sense.
Can you imagine being one of these people on this panel?
What do you have a password for at the library?
That's what I'm saying.
I guess to get into,
to look at the Internet and stuff.
Oh,
right,
right.
That's why she doesn't like the Internet anymore.
She's there talking about her marital problems and shit and my husband won't
help me give her a penny.
My step mom won't help me.
A Nice,
by the way,
in a divorce,
even a divorce.
She just needs to be heard today.
That's my favorite.
I wouldn't do that to you.
You know,
can we,
you know,
this morning I was like,
I was like,
Babe,
I love you and want to stay married forever.
Please.
Let's never divorce.
And you were just like,
oh,
there's a new Verizon that opened up down the street.
And I'm like,
I'm looking for reassurance.
I'm looking for,
I love you will never get a divorce.
Can you say that to me,
Tom?
Well,
so because it was in the city of Davenport acad she was the city of Davenport.
Do you know where that is?
I don't care.
It's a divorce town for you.
Hello?
Are we going to stay together forever or not you?
I mean everything happens for a reason to stop it.
No crime.
Not getting a divorce.
No,
we're not going to get the word.
Why don't we get a divorce?
I'm just making sure that you're in it to win it.
I am.
We have children together.
I know,
but some people don't care.
I got,
I mean,
I'm saying,
I don't know what's out there.
You know,
you know it's out there.
Road beef.
Yeah.
You've been,
you've been out there before.
We get married.
We'll see.
So a dumb you keeping your options open.
I mean,
I mean everyone's got it.
Let me tell you something.
What woman out there is going to clean out your ear hair?
Like
here's the deal,
man.
I need to be soft a lot there.
Do you know that?
That's a clip that I still think about a lot to try out.
Think about him all the time.
I still think about him.
I think about my grandfather and him the most weight,
but I'm,
I'm trying to make a point,
which is we were at Starbucks yesterday and I noticed you are growing dad ear
hair.
You're not even 40 but you're a dad and that's what happens.
And then later that day I cleaned out your ear hair for you in the kitchen.
Oh,
that's love.
You love me.
Yeah.
Like Chris Rock says new.
He's not going to clean out your fucking ear hair.
Yes he does.
He says new pussy.
He says as your,
your hair.
But you're nasty.
You got to hear here and know his hair.
Yeah,
I know,
I know.
And here's the other thing,
new.
He doesn't like it.
They're like,
oh yeah,
they're always like your ear hair cause you do you think you could fucking trim
your ear here before I bought the bang bus and I'm like,
yeah,
yeah.
Hold on a second.
I can't even carry more.
How many times a day do you think I say,
are you even listening to me when you're on your iPhone yet you're listening to
me.
Yeah,
I'm here.
I can hear you.
That's fucking hear you fine
your hair.
Fuck.
You know the funny thing is somebody mentioned to you,
you have like crazy ear hair.
You,
you immediately can't stop thinking about it.
I know you said it was,
you can't,
you can't pull it out really.
You know,
like you're just like,
wait,
there's hair growing out of my ears right now and you are such a dad about it.
What are you listening to me?
Yes,
I'm listening to you.
God.
Constant.
It's like having a teenager.
Um,
and I,
I kept,
I pulled it a little so you could feel where it was done.
Yeah,
I know.
But then you still couldn't get it on your own.
What good is it here?
And you kept like digging in the tremor and like get with the program to add.
I know.
And then I asked you to give me head scratchies last night.
You love head scratches.
That's our currency.
Yeah.
But here's the thing.
Some people will understand this and then some people won't,
but so for those of you that don't know,
she loves like head scratch it.
So what happens is you need,
like if you're laying in bed,
you need it to be where your hand naturally lays.
Nobody.
No,
that's the only way he'll gimme scratchies is if you,
if you,
you're like,
yeah,
as long as your head is right here,
that's a reasonable thing to right here.
But you can't like bend your arm.
Okay.
That's what the elbows for.
No,
this is not comfortable to sit there and scratch like this.
So I just want like,
Hey,
could you be here?
So you were here and all I did was,
oh my God,
just your head.
No.
Yeah,
I was falling asleep.
You're scratching and then you go,
you push my head like,
like you push one of the dogs like I was a Brussels girl.
Fine.
I then pushed me.
I didn't go like this.
No,
no.
You were here and I just went like this.
Like a dog.
Like I was one of the dogs.
And then you got continued head scratches.
Not for long.
They were very poor quality.
Oh,
okay.
They were set apart.
Scratchies I mean,
you're talking shit about the scratchies you're getting,
they weren't very good.
He gave up and you think I fall asleep when I don't notice on the bagging bus.
Everybody is appreciative.
All right.
You don't give head scratches to those slots.
I,
they don't get scratched.
That's a wife move.
But scratchies as soon as they,
as soon as they mentioned head scratches,
we opened the bus where we just throw her plus her head out here.
Get out of here.
Lot Lizard take.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So we've been getting into,
you know,
we were like,
we're,
we,
we finished it or dirty John.
And you're watching what's that show called now on Netflix borrowed you.
You fucking love that.
She now,
but I haven't gotten anything ripped through it.
I'm done.
Okay.
So I need to start watching that.
So what we did is we found season one of 90 day fiance.
Yeah.
Which was a great move.
I got to say,
you know,
we get into these shows and they've been on for awhile and I'm like,
I don't want to watch the old season.
You know,
and then you realize,
well that's why you're on this new season.
Cause the old seasons.
Good.
Yeah.
Fantastic.
Great show.
Now the problem with the early episodes of 90 day fiance is that they actually
find intrinsically good girl.
Yeah.
I like that.
They found like nice girls that actually love these guys.
It's really weird.
I don't like that.
So there's this fucking Dork who's from out here.
They're all doors,
he's a Mormon and he's God fucking smoke show.
That would definitely make Josh come and he's just like,
well he's a fucking 30 he's like,
ah,
I'm Mormon and I'm going to wait until marriage.
So he has his dork friend come over and chaperone them and he's like,
you lay here and make sure I don't go crazy and fucker
the night with his friend in the living room and she's like a 20 year old girl
from Brazil,
a tiny favela as shit dog talent.
She's never even had running water in her house.
And so he,
you know,
show higher
teenager.
No,
she's not.
She's like,
I've never,
and he's like,
this is the hot water.
She is called built to spin on a Knob,
80 pounds.
She's tiny little Phillips,
like a Chihuahua.
I mean if Josh couldn't come with her then,
then nobody can come down.
No,
no,
no.
Yeah.
Anyways,
yeah.
This dork had his fucking nerd friend.
Why then why are you bringing these floods over here if you're not banging them?
And then another nurse,
I thought that would be like the pay toll,
you know,
that's a tall,
that's the price you pay for bringing over the,
I was like rubbing my hands go like,
oh,
he's going to fuck so much right now.
And then.
Then there's another Dork,
the Colombian girl.
Now she's built her fuck gorge and she comes over.
She's like,
I'm ready to pay the price.
She was like,
my morning
coming my hair.
She's made a comment.
She goes,
and then I get these CTC shape,
right?
He's like,
absolutely,
sweetie,
whatever you up.
Yeah.
No.
She's like,
she actually really proud more than he does.
She's in him and he lives in Oklahoma with his mommy and daddy and he's 27 years
old.
I'm like,
Bro,
you brought this chick over.
Go Invest in renting apartment in Oklahoma where I'm sure you can get an
apartment for $10 a month or whatever.
The cost of living.
Is there another,
this is,
I think we just saw solve the Josh dilemma was that we're for potter.
Yeah.
Used to be on one of these sites and bring over a fucking foreign,
a foreign come dog dog who,
great idea who's like,
I want the American life is like,
I need to come and then perfect exchange set up.
Well,
that is the exchange.
It's I want American life.
Well,
I need to come peanut butter and chocolate go well together.
You fuck a lot.
I let you stay.
Exactly.
And here's the best part is that you don't have to be wealthy.
You just need to have an apartment and a mattress on the floor,
like an air mattress.
These tricks are fine.
They're totally fine.
They're like,
it has air in it.
They're really impressed.
Especially some of these real third worlders like the Philippines,
like those chicks are just happy to have a roof over their head.
This Brazilian checks.
Now the Russians are a little more high Falutin.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well she's,
you know,
she's obviously a spy but she,
she,
she kind of eyeballs things.
She also does the slow play with him.
She's like,
we're not going to fuck right away.
Right?
No,
she smiled.
we'll wait a minute.
Yeah,
but I think a lot of those season one,
a couples are still together.
I think you're right.
Cause they picked nice girls.
They didn't,
they figured it out.
They figure it out.
As the seasons progressed,
like we got to get some fucking psychopath,
some real users and users,
man,
shit to watch,
trying to make a love show now.
And so what's even crazier is that,
um,
my,
so embarrassing,
I found a picture of my dad's recent wedding yeah.
To his 90 day fiance.
Wild.
And let me tell Ya,
like my dad's literally living this TV show.
Yeah.
And I haven't,
I haven't met her,
I'm not talking currently to my dad for a few reasons we won't get into on this
show.
But,
um,
I saw a picture of my new mom.
And what do you think?
She's pretty,
she's a real young in her thirties and they're wearing like,
um,
Vietnamese traditional wedding.
But at the cool thing is my dad went comfy cause he's wearing as good sneakers.
So the wedding
she's paying that toll.
Right.
So I definitely thinking she's,
she's paying the common goal.
That's exactly what it has to be.
Right.
Because he's probably like,
I want somebody to cook and clean,
but also somebody I can fuck.
And she's like,
great,
I don't like Vietnam.
Sounds good to me.
I like to live in the valley.
Number two,
if you're out there,
hey
you can,
you could get an American,
you don't need those are for nerds dude.
Okay.
The 90 day fiance,
they're all fucking dorks.
You're a celebrity.
You know what I'm saying?
Right.
You get some American pig.
Okay.
What do you think she would be like?
What do you think it would seriously,
well if I was,
if my dad's step mom,
if I was on number two,
what would it be like?
What you think she would mind telling you?
I definitely not a foreign girl.
No,
cause you're too American.
Like you are American.
You like American.
Yeah,
you like blonds but she'd have to be real dumb.
I'm telling you like you want a Dalmatian,
one of the fuck do I need it?
That was the first wife is always like the real life and then the second wife is
like the no static wife.
Like,
all she wants to do is like yoga all day.
And she's like,
I am in tig,
gluten free diet.
And she just talks about keenwah or whatever.
And then you strap on her conversations and she's like,
I've tried to get Todd to lose weight eating way too much dairy.
No,
but all she does.
Yeah.
She's like a yoga instructor.
All right,
cool.
That's all she does tolerate our children home.
You owe no man.
No,
I don't know.
Tolerate that kids.
They,
she's not,
she doesn't want a kid,
right?
Might be at mom.
No,
no,
no.
My second wife.
Oh No,
they always want kids.
That's a problem with the second wife.
What about Mike?
That's the,
that's the,
so here's the problem with my new Vietnam too,
is that she's probably young enough.
Mom.
Mom is great.
Yeah.
But she definitely,
cause I think she's still Blair's my Viet mom.
Yeah.
She's definitely wanting kids and he's got to be,
he's 72 so that's not even ethical.
Right.
It's not ethical.
Fifth Grade,
your dad's 82
that's it.
Hold back.
It doesn't hold some people back,
but it's not cool.
High School graduation.
Oh my God,
you're great.
Great.
Granddad came.
Um,
yeah,
but the second wife is always,
she always wants kids so you have to do it again.
Look at Alec Baldwin.
He's on,
he's there.
Five words.
Yeah,
he's 60.
He's got a new family.
Those kids won't know him very well.
What about my second husband?
Let's talk about it.
What is what,
what do you think would have a B is second husband.
If you're the woman,
his second husband at down man.
I'm just thinking about my name mom.
I can just imagine Hoenlein Casey.
My Dad though.
Cause he's such a savage like I think that's why he likes like foreign checks
cause American women will be like go fuck yourself.
Oh yeah,
no,
they would not like I've heard him complained to his American girlfriend one
time that he did have what?
He was like,
you know,
you working too much.
Why don't you bring me a plate of Salami or a beer or something.
I'm fucking hungry and all I to cook for me.
Clean up the house.
And she was like,
what?
Like American women had their heads explode when I dude says some crazy shit to
them.
But like Vietnam is probably like too your phone,
but she say sort of the ax.
Oh really?
You like more plan?
Do they only do nails and Vietnamese?
They don't do massage.
Right.
I don't know that.
That's
okay.
Do you think he gets free Manny?
Petty's it's possible.
I don't know.
I Dunno.
So yeah,
he's probably,
he's probably having a good time,
dude.
You could have,
I mean,
if your dad had an interest in them,
you could have had a Vietnam too.
Like you could have been oh yeah.
Oh yeah.
You don't think he ever had some Vietnamese ladies during the war?
Uh,
he said no and I didn't,
you know,
I mean,
it was like after,
he's like,
no,
I mean,
he,
he said no and you know,
he would he be the kind to just come out and say,
I mean,
he told me all about who he fucked on a r and r one time.
Yeah.
Like when they have like a break.
He's like,
yeah,
we went to Australia.
God start with the hottest chick in the room and the gods and then we just,
God,
we really enjoyed ourselves so grows her for a week and I'm like,
all right,
well you were big tits full blush.
Oh yeah.
He kept telling me,
I was like,
cool man.
Yeah.
You kept talking about like you're getting the dog and I would so gross.
You're talking about how my new mom makes my dad cause my dad is still,
he's sexually active.
That's the thing.
It's like if he's 72 here's the thing,
how that sweet Vietnamese lady,
it's not as easy as,
Hey,
I'm ready to do it.
She's got to go to work a to get that thing ready to perform and to make it
finish.
It doesn't work the same way at 72 has 16 right.
You know 16 you feel a breeze.
You're like,
oh,
okay.
Yeah,
that's 72 she's got to put them,
she's go ahead,
put his legs back.
Day changes died.
I like the scram.
Oh,
you got to spend 20 minutes there.
Then he's like,
oh,
it's up now.
Yeah.
It's not just thinking about my dad's boners just bus inner and honor.
And here's the deal man.
Like when I think about it,
what he really wants is a housekeeper and a cook and you could buy one of those
but then we kind of did,
well that's what I'm saying.
But the,
the extra bonus is that he can bust nuts in his housekeeper.
Like that's basically all this is like you,
you probably could have just found some nice lady local,
right?
Who Cook and clean for you.
Maybe legal buzz,
Knutsen earn to maybe this is real love and we're being rude about it.
You don't know.
She's like 10 years younger than me dude.
Perfect.
You didn't give him what you want to be able to 72 year old guy.
Absolutely.
30 something.
You're almost fucking on your 30 close your eyes and go back to being 30 Yup.
Yup,
Yup.
Wasn't your perfect guy like seven
mm.
Let me think about it.
Nice.
40 year age gap,
right?
Is
Skin all wrinkly and we know like,
oh,
just a few more years and like get to have it.
Yep.
Ah,
it's so crazy.
She's probably thinking about her next marriage too.
Oh yeah.
Cause I definitely,
I mean that,
that's gotta be the plan,
right?
She's thinking how long do I have to ride this out?
I mean,
how many more years?
Really?
Yeah.
And then she still will be,
you know,
relatively young and you should reach out.
Do you think our children need to know all this?
Sure.
They think they want to be a part of,
could you imagine having her over and acting like any of this is remotely
normal?
Because that's the next,
that is the reach out.
Unfortunately,
if I were then,
if she came over and she was like,
can I marry your son?
Oh,
Ellis or Julian,
the promise like royalty,
they turn 15 primary though.
Yeah.
She becomes a family sock puppet.
Oh my God.
The generational pig got me on that one.
I wasn't expecting that.
I can't even imagine the,
the bullshit I'd have to go through like pretending that this is remotely okay a
lot.
They're like,
hi,
what's your name?
Like what's even,
what are their names?
Like Vietnamese named tweet.
I don't tweet.
I don't even know.
Like what are real?
Because they all at the nail salon,
they always go by like Judy or you know Tracy though your name's not fucking
Tracy.
A lot of a lot of people are lasting was dwin.
That's the Smith of Vietnam,
right?
Yeah.
I'll be like,
hey,
hey Trey.
Again,
I think she,
I mean you don't know.
She could be lovely.
No,
I know it's,
she could be totally,
yeah,
it's absurd.
Like I,
I just like nobody in my family is normal.
Like not one,
not one.
The one that is normal moved away.
The one I liked and everybody damn it.
And I'm stuck with all these fucking crazy people,
man.
I know God damn it now.
Or we're going to need to see that wedding video.
I got to go to my therapy.
I got to go three times this week.
Got To triple up.
Yup.
Yeah.
Cause I,
I remember when we saw that he therapy this week.
Where's Dr Drew?
I saw that picture.
The picture is really what personally?
Yeah.
I turned it to a telescope.
I turned it into a telescope.
When you see my dad's wedding photo.
Yeah.
I did fucking crazy.
That really?
Except oof.
I was,
yeah.
Some else guys.
Yeah.
Um,
head's still spinning from that one.
There was,
it was really something.
So he's got the Kimono on or whatever the fuck that shit is.
No one thing that we're going to call that shit with sneakers.
Kimono.
Yeah.
I'm like a fucking Vietnamese like wedding garb.
Come on.
Oh,
Sharon on the fuck it's called and then she's wearing it and he's wearing his
white ass sneakers too.
Like,
look,
cool.
You are,
you're good sneakers.
That's,
hey,
that's what happens to older people though.
They don't give a fuck.
Yeah.
It's always about foot comfort though.
That's how I am now.
I respect it.
Like those shoes don't,
oh,
don't feel good.
Um,
I respect it.
So,
oh,
Oscar's where a few weeks ago,
the only thing we took a peek at was a who fucking Bradley Cooper and Lady Kaka
Ma did a song together.
That's their,
their big hit song.
And they,
they looked at each other.
Yeah.
Just like they were in the movie,
they had been performing the song a bit,
but,
uh,
and they looked at each other with like,
I'm gonna fuck you eyes,
right as they perform the song.
Bradley Cooper's baby Momma's like in the front room now disrespect.
And it's,
you know,
it's a performance,
but the way the these two,
oh my God.
And they real hearing on like,
it's,
they get intense man.
I know.
Can I tell you something too?
Uh,
I would rather go to my dad's wedding with my new Vietnamese mom.
Then watch them sing this song together.
It's uncarved see this movie.
Yeah.
This whole fucking nonsense movie of them singing and stuff.
I can't think of anything worse.
Well,
they,
uh,
they really,
really love.
All right.
I know.
And I tried watching the clip and I realized the movie that I hate slow songs.
I hate slow songs too.
No,
I would never watch it.
That's what I'm saying.
I would rather him fucking go to Vietnam and go to my dad's wedding,
then watch the fucking movie.
It's so terrible.
The,
uh,
what's it called?
The,
um,
that 90 day fiance.
Yeah.
They do this thing where like whenever the couples do have like a loving moment,
they start playing light.
Yeah.
I hate it.
Can feel your hate,
that kind of music.
And then like a guitar strums and it's like this little montage of them.
Yeah.
I hate that.
I hate it so much and I didn't realize how much I hated it until I tried
watching this clip that everybody was talking about between Lady Gaga,
lady cop,
Bradley Cooper,
and I couldn't even get through the music.
I'm like,
ugh.
I hate the emotion.
Yeah.
I hate the only song I ever liked that was slow was the Whitney Houston the
greatest love of all.
Yeah,
that was great.
Well,
I like,
I like a lot of Whitney stuff.
No,
no tea.
Yeah.
But because I don't like watching a lot of those kinds of performances.
No,
I don't like watching that shit either.
And I don't like those songs.
I don't like,
yeah,
I don't like it.
I'll leave a restaurant or us a store.
Yeah.
It starts playing music.
Like that means,
yeah.
Get the fuck out,
but uh,
but going back to your point of them being very intensely sexual.
Yeah.
Uh,
if that was me in the audience and you are Bradley Cooper,
I'd find go rip.
That bitch is necklace off.
Really Eddie,
I'm fucking choke her out with it.
Rip that stupid bar off her head.
Well,
deck.
That's a perfect lead in because it got me thinking about what about mean we
work in this business?
What about me doing a love?
No.
Would
you just not ever watch it?
I would never watch it.
I don't ever want to see you Matt kissing somebody else or making pretend.
That's where we're different.
Kisses and licks.
Are you kidding me?
If you tell,
if you had a love scene,
I would go in there with lube and I'd be like,
let's see what's up and I would just get to and right away the cod.
Yeah.
Are So nasty time if you're like,
no,
it's a train scene where it's like six guys.
I'd be like,
even better.
I've just booked a small part in a movie.
I know.
Congratulations.
Yeah,
shoots in a couple of months.
It's not romantic.
It's a very,
first of all,
I didn't know this,
but Hollywood sees me as a love men as a leading love man.
That's not true.
They,
they see me and they're like,
this is who America wants to see,
making love to women on camera.
And so it's a very romantic part.
Um,
it's called,
um,
I play this guy.
Uh,
I think it's Jake the hammer
and he just,
he hammers girls.
Really?
Okay.
What's the par for real?
Can you say,
are you allowed to say?
Uh,
I can say that I'm a tech guy.
Yeah.
Are you an asshole in it?
That's your type.
Thank you.
That's why I married you.
You're a lovable.
A whole.
Yeah,
but there's a love scene.
No,
there's not a shower.
Love saying stop it.
The tech guy doesn't ever get a shower.
Lhotse.
Yes,
he does.
And this one.
Oh,
stop it.
Yeah,
but we don't know.
So what'd you really don't watch it?
No,
I couldn't be able to.
I wouldn't be able to.
Would you be able to watch me?
I would watch it because I know you'd be like,
don't watch it
because you'd be like,
do not watch it.
I'd be like,
I want to go watch your feet feel.
Would you feel anything you think?
What do you mean jealousy of what?
Are you even listening to me?
Yeah,
never listen.
I am listening.
If I was Frenching Bradley Cooper and a movie and we were laughing and stuff.
Yeah,
you wouldn't feel any sort of way about it.
Of course I would feel a certain way about it.
They'll be like,
oh,
she doesn't usually French me like that.
Okay,
back man,
you've got so much tongue.
And if you're like,
and now I know,
put your legs behind your house.
There are well movie.
Nobody.
No woman wants to do that to anybody who would do that to Bradley now.
Not to Bradley Cooper.
I would do it to Ryan Gosling.
Gosling.
I would do it too.
Um,
I like Jake John Hall.
Oh,
these are new new additions.
Okay.
We were,
we were going to book them around now or not.
You're happy now.
Oh,
spot.
You fucking stupid woman.
Dumb Bitch.
You stupid fucking bitch.
I like Jake Gyllenhaal.
I like Ryan Gosling too.
I would put in,
I would do the dog and she uses their scrum.
Jesus Christ.
See,
I can see Gosling being like,
I don't,
he's watching.
Yeah.
He'd be like,
I don't want to do that to you.
But I could see Jillian hall just be like,
eat it and then hold your head back there and you're like,
Ooh,
I can't breathe.
He's like,
shut up.
And then I don't think so.
I think he's really sweet.
None.
And I think he's a really,
I don't think so.
I think he's a savage.
I think he would step on your neck.
Put your head in the trash.
Yeah.
And I gotta tell you I'm getting worked up thinking about it,
but I'm not a super jealous type anyway.
You're very mellow.
But I also feel like you know,
you,
you make me feel that way.
I make you feel safe.
Yeah.
I try.
I'm not thinking,
I don't like to wind people up like that.
I think that's cruel to play games with people.
Yeah.
I don't like that shit together like 15 years now.
So you're saying you're going to stay married to me?
Uh,
for at least 2019.
I'm never letting you divorced or never divorcing.
Yeah.
I'm never going to let you.
Well I'm fucking so stupid.
Sled around my kids away.
Just like you take your bank bus and you come back when you get this out of your
system.
Ah,
nope.
Oh Man.
No.
I'd be like,
guess what?
We're coming out with a bang butts with you.
Oh,
bring the kids and my whole game.
No way dude.
Come in to see you on the road,
Daddy.
Oh yeah.
Shrink that wiener.
Oh my God.
Right now there's just like these bowls with condoms in every corner of Donbass
stop to wherever you are.
You can please.
You're grabbing me anyways guys,
I'm,
I wanted to bring everybody's attention.
Thank you everybody who tweeted out to Kelly,
deal of the breeders.
You guys are amazing.
And I have an update,
big Y on h exclusive.
We've been dming each other back and forth on Twitter and they currently,
the breeders don't have any dates for la yet,
but I'll flee when they do.
Uh,
we hopefully will get them in.
So we're,
we're in communications right now,
so thank you guys for making that happen.
Ben,
which is very exciting.
I've got a really awesome thing to play for you.
So,
you know,
Fort Simpson,
of course.
I Know Bart Simpson,
Dj skull vomit.
He,
wow.
They,
Shelly always blows us away.
Um,
so a few weeks ago,
you know,
we introduced you to hard rock nick.
Good looking rich guys,
right?
With his touched.
Yeah.
He's,
he's got a lot going on that show.
I like pink pussies.
Okay.
So
he,
uh,
he really opened our eyes to how cool.
He was definitely chairman of the cool guy,
club,
founding member.
I found her and,
and member.
Oh yeah.
So he,
yeah,
he,
he blew us away.
The cool,
the coolest guy we've ever seen.
And um,
fart does these parts amazing prank calls?
Well,
he did one with hard rock,
nick.
Oh,
your kid.
And it's really great.
Oh my God.
I can't wait.
So without further ado,
here is the Fart Simpson Prank phone call with hard rock.
Nick <UNK>.
This is hard rock,
nick.
Yeah,
I'm hard rock nick.
Okay,
hard rock.
Nick,
how are you?
What's up?
Uh,
I don't know.
You called me.
What's up?
You're tired of everybody else on TV and in the movies and on sports.
Okay.
I'm here for you and I'm going to run with you until we can't run anymore.
Okay?
It might me.
I'm the best looking man on the planet.
No bullshit.
Okay.
That's what's up.
I'm the real deal.
So you call him and tell him you're the real deal.
I'm worth 350 million.
I'm a fucking millionaire 75 times over.
Okay.
I've never been to acting school.
That's okay.
I didn't ask to be a famous person.
Okay.
Wilson won.
Mike got the baddest ass hole in the game.
No.
Um,
I got a big Dick.
Wonderful.
You think that's fake?
Oh,
absolutely.
100%.
I don't know who you are.
You're not anything to make bitch.
I'm a rich guy.
I'm going to be good no matter what.
Okay,
well I don't think I can leave and all this shit.
You'd be reading on the Internet and I don't think are going to do anything for
you there.
Listen,
you fucking asshole piece of shit.
Little Dick Insecure mother fucking con.
Nice promise to keep it sexy.
Sounds good.
You want me?
No,
I don't want you,
I promise to keep a gangster.
Okay,
sure.
Oh Wow.
Really well done.
Actually.
Just sounds like a regular hard rock,
Nicole.
Oh,
that sounds like a prank.
Call it all that really well.
I think he does just have calls like that,
right?
Poor guy that answers.
Yeah.
In a weird way.
It feels like he's handled calls like that before.
No,
he's like,
what?
What?
Ah,
what?
I mean,
that's pretty funny.
Okay.
No,
let me address that too,
cause that's some more retarded shit I'm going to get.
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
You use it all on
a man?
No,
nothing.
Oh,
we're good.
We're good.
That was pretty funny.
Jeans.
That guy is really something special,
Huh?
Yeah,
he really is super special.
Um,
Jean,
you were in Oklahoma.
Yeah,
it wasn't,
I've been pronouncing the town wrong forever.
It's siloed springs.
I've been saying Cylo em for like months.
Salamae yeah,
fantastic show.
I want to thank everybody that came out to the Cherokee casino.
I mean,
people came from everywhere.
Fayetteville,
Bentonville surrounding areas.
Wonderful.
But the actual town of Salem is like,
they had a Mcdonald's,
they had a donut shop and then a grocery store.
That was it.
And they're like,
well this is the center of the city and my driver.
And um,
everybody was really great except for one.
The guy that picked me up at the airport,
he was so are worded so special.
How do I say it?
Touched duty showed up a half hour late.
Okay.
When there's no traffic,
there's no traffic.
Um,
so I call him when I notice he's a little bit late and um,
and I was like,
where are you dude?
And he's like,
well,
I'm about 10 minutes away.
And I'm like,
cool.
Just texts me when you arrive.
He's,
and then click hang up.
20 minutes go by.
And I'm like,
where is this guy?
And I call him and I'm like,
hey dude,
where are you at?
What's your ETA?
And he goes,
are you in the baggage claim?
And like,
yeah,
where are you?
He goes,
hold on,
I'm going to come inside.
I'm like,
wait,
you're here?
And then he comes in and he's like,
hey,
how you doing?
How's your day?
And I'm like,
uh,
I goes,
great.
I woke,
I will give a 5:00 AM I flew across the country and then I got to spend a half
hour in this cool airport,
so I just want to thank you.
And he's like,
he goes away,
I can tell you're being sarcastic.
He got that.
He got,
he picked up on that.
He goes to your band sarcastic now.
And I was like,
yeah.
And I go,
Bro,
I the show's going to go,
no,
I was kind of worried.
I'm like,
this is indicative of everybody.
And so we get in the car and um,
and I goes,
hey,
so I see,
I told you to text me like,
when you got here,
how long have you been parked out here?
And he goes,
I've been here for about 10 minutes and I go,
I told you to call me and I go,
if I hadn't called you,
what would you have done?
And he goes,
I would have kept waiting.
I'm like,
oh my God.
Thanks man.
It was so weird in that.
Yeah,
I was so like what dude?
So yeah,
that was the only weird thing.
It was so weird.
That's kind of weird.
Completely retarded.
Yeah.
That was interesting.
But everybody else,
super nice.
They do just do everything slower on that part of the country though.
You know,
I I,
yeah,
I had to get myself a lot longer,
you know.
Yeah.
Cause they just don't,
there's like La,
we have a sense of urgency for shit.
Same with New York,
but now these folks,
man,
you gotta you gotta be on Oklahoma Time,
Arkansas time.
Hey,
why don't we take a quick moment,
a break here and we'll be right back and we are back with the stars of corporate
on comedy central season two airs Tuesdays at 10:30 PM
Jake Weisman,
Matt Anger,
Sinemet.
I even wrote it down.
You know what,
you are racist for getting that wrong.
Wow.
No Nordic one tech lingo.
Breton,
biking.
Can't you tell?
It's got to feel good to be that tall.
I saw it.
It does feel good.
And just to say it,
I'm Jewish.
So there's a Jew in the room and we'll talk about it as much as you want.
How does this work?
How does our work?
And we were kind of like an s and m relationship cause they just fucked up.
But like when you found out where you're like,
yeah,
I've learned this is what he writes me off a tax wise word showbiz.
That's massive.
You need a Jew in your corner.
Trust me.
I know how Golden,
yeah,
I feel bad,
but everyone wants me.
We work with Lieberman,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
Just congratulations.
That's a tier one juice stuff.
Yeah.
My name is Jacob Aaron Gladstone Weissman.
I would have been hunted down in Germany.
The first name would have been like,
well you're definitely dead.
Yeah,
but we're not even going to make you a garden,
but we're just going to fucking kill you as you are.
So Joe spreads his seat.
It'd be terrible.
Um,
no.
So season two,
congratulations on that.
Congratulations on the miracle of getting a show on the air.
It is article.
Yeah.
I mean I,
I just,
another friend of mine just got greenlit to make a feature and I was like,
Whoa,
it's amazing with that.
I've never heard.
Now of course we don't get to make it.
Yeah.
It's weird.
Like so many people we know have made livings for 20 years by selling things
that they know will never get made.
I'm just going to write it in my room and our,
I can write it from anywhere.
It's weird to make a cooler that way.
You actually did it.
We did it.
I almost feel like it's this weird thing where because we got to make it so,
so early into our careers or like within like the first decade,
it's like we're never going to get to do it again.
Like it's just setting us up to be like,
no,
this was just your chain.
Are you enjoying it?
Are you having fun doing?
It's great.
It's beyond a dream cause you get to like write and direct and cast and produce
it.
It's like why are you letting us do that?
Like it doesn't really make any sense.
It was like a giant playground that costs a ton of money and we,
and we're responsible to make sure that money is used well done that thing yet
where you go like what?
What if we did this?
And then they go like that would be like 50,000 just for that shot.
And you're like,
yes we have.
Yeah we have.
What's interesting when you like write and make the show is like when you're
writing a show you're like,
oh it'd be so funny if we like went to the desert and blah blah blah and then
like cut to three months later we got to go to the fucking,
does it have like a weird combo buys find that a lot.
Yeah.
With like Matt,
there's a lot in the show of Matt just getting hit and so,
and we don't realize you're going to have to get hit like 30 times if you write
it in with all the different angles.
And you have to be like it's going to be,
or if you write that you're going to be in your underwear,
like you're going to be in your fucking underwear,
that'd be naked.
You don't think about it cause you have to just do the funniest possible thing.
But it is kind of an angry God.
We have perfect bodies and look right in there.
Now did you guys come from a sketch background?
Yeah,
well we did.
It was sad.
It was sketch because we were doing standup for like a decade or whatever in La
and just try and do as much as possible and then we were simultaneously doing
videos sketch so it wasn't like live sketch.
It was like making short films just like yes,
this almost no way around it.
Yes,
it's honestly I reckon it's kind of what you almost have to do now.
Like you guys,
I don't know if you make videos,
sketches,
but you do a lot of standup but I think most people coming out now pretty much
have to do both.
Like it's what a comedian is,
is way different than it was 20 years ago.
I think,
and you have to kind of know how to write direct edit,
like caste act,
all that stuff,
just to get a chance to make your own thing,
you know,
just so you can just stand up and came from that school doing those youtube
because it used to be like,
it used to almost be like you did stand up so he could get a show and now it's
almost like you make many shows online so you can go tour,
stand up and it's,
it's weird and it's,
it's just changing all the time.
Yeah.
Well luckily you guys are doing great,
like you did it,
but it's kind of our sketch show in a way.
Right.
You know,
you need this in order for people to come see you.
It's a totally different kind of thing.
It feeds itself.
It's a weird,
it's weird being a comedian.
Yeah,
it's very,
it's great
you guys saying this because somebody's listening.
Like I just worked with a fifth year of comic and she was like,
my parents don't support me and my decision,
I'm like,
first of all,
don't ever expect support from fucking any.
They should you,
it's a stupid thing to do with your life,
you're probably not going to make it.
Yeah.
And secondly,
I was like,
you don't think at some point I was a five year comic and I was sitting in your
exact shoes and somebody watching you guys today,
they're like,
I could never make a TV show.
And you know what's funny is that there's,
there's this huge myth that things can't get made,
but you know,
networks need you more than you need them.
They need you.
We go in a lot of meetings and they're like,
we need something good.
Please just give us something good.
Like we're just desk.
Please just say the thing.
So we can say yes.
And if you just,
I would say one of the most important things right now is learn how to edit,
learn how to just even shoot and edit.
And if you and make things all the time and it takes a few years to get really
good and you're so,
you're going to be so happy you learned how to do it,
do it before you're too old to be annoyed at doing it.
And then learn how to do it and make stuff.
You really never know what can happen.
That being said,
I do my stock advice for people who are like,
should I get into this?
It's like,
no,
because if they,
if I talk them out of it good,
then they'd be like,
have a shot at a normal life.
Right?
Yeah.
But if they're like,
fuck you,
I'm gonna do it anyway,
then I've like inspired them.
And actually the only the people who go like,
Nah,
I'm fucking doing it or should be the ones that,
yeah,
that's exactly right.
So she would always say,
don't get into this.
Yeah,
of course.
Because the people always like,
I get hit up,
they're like,
uh,
you know,
I gotta I got like a,
like I have like an hour of material and I'm like,
yeah,
like,
but I haven't done it yet.
And I'm like,
yeah,
okay.
And then they're like,
I just haven't,
you know,
what should I do now?
I'm like,
I don't know,
man.
Like,
go do your hour and,
and then,
you know,
the,
I mean,
the answer's always the same.
Two was just like,
well,
just get on stage.
They're like,
where?
I'm like,
I don't know.
You figure it out,
figure it out.
It's almost like,
it's very interesting.
It's like it really is the type of person that does it is not someone who asks
too many questions.
Maybe you ask a few questions because it is a little scary at first.
Sure.
You get five questions and it's like,
go figure it out.
We all figured it out.
No one really has any answers.
They actually almost because someone has done it a certain way,
it almost means you have to do it a different way.
You almost just have to go into a blackout for five years,
um,
and then pop out and hope you've learned a few things.
Sometimes I've,
I feel like,
uh,
like some of the things that feel like a long time ago,
I'll stop.
You're like,
shit,
that was only like five years ago.
Yeah,
I know.
It feels like it was,
I'm talking about like my teenage years or something.
Yeah.
It's not that long ago.
Right.
You were 12,
five years ago.
[inaudible]
legal for you to have two kids.
I know it makes this personality that we all have to be in this business and
persist even though you're told no constantly and on this thing about not asking
questions like I was a latch key kids,
there was nobody to ask fucking figure it out.
Right?
You have to be so resilient and self sufficient.
You have to be a maniac,
got to live in poverty,
live core.
You have a terrible life.
You have to be uncomfortable to want to fight your way out of it.
Now what happens sometimes is some people then just do heroin instead.
If you don't do heroin,
you'll eventually make it up.
That's true.
So you were saying you're considering antidepressants because I mean I feel like
a large part of why I've been able to like make a living at least for the past
four or five years,
finally is like a comedian is because I was so unhappy.
Like,
I just feel like I'm so unhappy and I think the world is so bad and I want so
badly to have a good time,
so I'm miserable.
And I'm like,
well,
if I just go do five open mics tonight and then make a sketch to and don't sleep
and drink coffee and a mad,
then eventually I can fight my way out.
But now I haven't fought my way out.
I'm just making a good living right now.
And I'm like,
Oh,
I'm still unhappy.
The problem is me.
So I feel like I just,
but it's like,
I think there's a large part of,
if you're a comedian,
you,
you see things in a critical way a lot of times.
And I'm not just purely silly on stage or like purely selling what I'm saying.
So it's like I see things critically and um,
you sort of get trapped into thinking that,
well,
that's your income,
so you don't want to fuck with that.
You know what I mean?
I want to,
I want to look at things the same way.
So it's consistent,
but it's like,
but I'm,
but I'm not happy when it goes well.
Like when it goes well,
I'm like,
well,
whatever,
it doesn't matter.
I trick them,
you know?
So I just,
I just want to enjoy stuff.
You're so messed up.
Yeah.
I'm super fucked up
because here's the deal.
You'll get even successfully going up.
Yeah.
You get,
you get your everything you wanted and then you still are a piece of shit on the
inside.
You still feel it.
Yeah.
Have,
you know you're a fraud.
So it's like,
yeah,
you're just like,
oh dark.
So I would love to,
I would love to just be able to eat food,
enjoy it and be like,
wow,
my night was made.
Wow.
Good food.
Good,
delicious.
Someone said they loved me and it was nice.
The funniest thing.
I've experienced what you guys have experienced it.
I think another level of,
it's like doing a show.
I've done a couple shows in front of like thousands of people.
I like that moment is so wild.
It's such a rush.
But then cut to one hour later,
I'm like,
I'm pissing in a toilet alone.
You know what I mean?
Was like,
what?
What's that?
You know it's a bizarre.
Is that all there is?
That's the,
you know that song,
is that all there is?
Is that all there is my friends.
So let's keep dancing.
Is that all there is?
You make it?
Yes.
You still feel fucking empty and your parents don't like you and you know it's,
it's why you get into therapy or your parents like me.
I told you that your friends aren't love ages.
I'm great with thirds by charter parents.
I love meeting my girlfriend's parents.
Really?
Why?
Cause I'm fucking charming.
Tall,
white,
solid looking man.
It's like you have good job.
Yeah.
Like hi,
I'm a competent man.
Nice to meet you.
Yeah,
I'm on TV.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
Okay.
Yeah.
Really Nice job with this one.
So that'd be a big man.
Are you in therapy though?
I'm going back in.
You got to get those meds too,
man.
I'm going to get those meds because I feel like I've had enough comedian friends
who are like,
no,
you don't understand dude.
I feel pretty good right now.
And I'm like,
I've seen it.
Definitely changed a couple of,
yeah,
it'd be nice.
There's no reason for the side effects,
whatever they're going to be,
whether it's like I gained like a hundred pounds or I can't fuck anymore.
Or I start sweating whenever the TV changes a channel,
whatever it is.
I'm excited for that.
Yeah,
exactly.
You just transfer it.
Season three,
season three.
It's like maybe I'll go on antidepressants then do an episode about that and
it'll pay for itself.
There you go.
Perfect.
Yeah.
I'm glad you said something right before they got here.
We were right before the guy,
we were talking about your,
your dad.
Oh my fuck.
So my dad,
I'll just tell her how we found the picture I was on,
I was on,
uh,
social media,
relative posted a wedding picture of my dad in Vietnam,
uh,
with his new wife,
the full Vietnamese Regalia,
like the wedding regalia,
but he's still wearing white sneakers,
which is nice.
This is how you found out.
I knew that they were engaged like a while back and they think they probably got
married here,
but I think this is the foreign ceremony also,
like 10 years younger than me.
Mommy,
tiny little model.
Um,
so yeah,
it's fucking,
my parents are garbage.
They're just cramps.
So irresponsible.
Yeah.
My Dad's been married and divorced three times and still has no idea that he is
the problem.
You know what I mean?
Like has no idea.
He's like,
yeah,
women are just annoying.
I mean,
dude,
it's clearly you
like three times,
like,
and you're like,
yeah,
he,
um,
it's amazing,
isn't it?
He,
he was dating a woman who,
um,
who didn't want to sleep with them,
but he proposed to her.
So she would essentially be as nurse and it was like,
it was like for her,
this would have been his fourth wife.
And she's like,
no,
what are you talking about?
I don't want to,
I don't want to fucking be here and I'll just be your friend.
Leave me alone.
I know what my dad's doing.
It's,
I want you to cook and clean and be able to fuck you.
Yeah.
Cool.
Good arrangement.
I tell you what's scary though.
My Dad is 85.
I have an old dad and I have two older sisters who were in their sixties yeah,
it's crazy.
So I was the third marriage and I was the only boy.
So he,
he's the,
he tells me all these old sperm,
yeah,
I'm old school.
I'm so imagine what I could have been from what I could have been,
I could have been a serial killer.
You know what I mean?
I could have had that kind of energy.
I would have been happy,
but I'm just no empathy.
I would have been so happy.
Serial killers.
Pretty cool.
[inaudible] got a bad rap on this last shot.
You know?
What did he do wrong?
So he's really,
yeah,
he really so good at it really bums me out though.
We're never going to see anyone like that again because of forensics and DNA.
Now we're going to put up bodies like maybe Garth Brooks,
but
Garth got bodies for sure.
I Chris Gaines,
alter ego.
It was just a,
just a fucking straight up murder,
like the dark hair.
It's like stopping Moody fucking that countryside.
Here's how they're going to do either you have to be a high profile celebrity,
like a Garth Brooks or like r Kelly.
He got away with shit for a long time.
That was a weird bond.
After three days in jail and you're like,
what?
You know what's weird?
You know what's weird about that?
What I truly don't relate to with people like that,
it's like he's been doing bad stuff for so long.
He doesn't,
he doesn't seem to be stressed about who are our Kelly.
That's amazing.
Right now.
What I'm actually thinking about is something I said to someone at a party two
years ago.
You know what I mean and I'm stressed out about it.
I'm like,
I fuck up,
but he just is like,
no,
I'm just going to do horrible things.
I'm not going to worry about,
it's fine.
I'm going to hope for a new space jam and write that soundtrack too.
He and it's like,
wow,
how do you not stress about shit?
They'd Cosby,
same thing.
He'd come out of court doing impressions,
walked out of court.
We get locked out of the court.
When he got convicted,
it's not like so there are walk out of court,
you've been convicted,
you're going to be sending,
and he goes like,
oh.
They're like,
hey,
and they're like,
dude,
I feel like we did right now
we need to figure out more specific punishments for these people because
even when he was walking out,
he was like,
I'm not going to bill Cosby.
I'm not going to jail Kelly tape.
I shouldn't have to repent for any crimes.
I'm so fixated on the fact that he has sold definitely over 30 million albums
and he definitely has toward for 25 years.
So many hits thing.
I mean,
just like so much income generated and they're like,
post $100,000 bond to get out of jail.
He's like,
I don't have it.
I know.
Just like being like,
I'll,
it'll get figured out.
It's so stressful.
I'm so stressed.
I just,
I just went over my taxes.
I just went over my taxes,
which are just fine,
not a ton of money.
And I was like,
I'm going to jail.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm reporting it accurately,
but I'm gonna miss one thing and I'm gonna go to jail.
And he's just like,
no,
I'm going to do horrible things for two decades.
Women in a dungeon in my house in Atlanta.
That's the other thing I don't relate to.
Those are,
those are right.
You can write those off actually.
So that's the other,
oh my God,
they're just so like,
they have so much energy to keep being bad,
you know,
not even tired.
50 and he's not tired.
Yeah.
That's exactly right.
That's how we feel about people that have these pro click sexual proclivities
that are very involved.
Like people that are in to
jerk off and go to sleep,
man.
But you got to buy shit.
Meet other people and room.
Exactly.
You gotta be there Saturday at one like that.
You have to buy a harness.
What if I take antidepressants and all the sudden I only can come off being fuck
while wearing a diaper.
I'm really worried.
One of my friends is happier than ever and he's like,
but I have zero sensitivity.
Yeah.
And he's like,
I cannot feel anything on my d.
Like it's just,
that's what I've heard top.
Yeah.
But I guess he doesn't care
being depressed and he fucks I fuck.
But I don't think I do it well anymore.
I don't really care how it ends.
It'll be bad for my girl for sex is like a movie without a third act falls apart
at the great.
So wait,
do you have trouble finishing though?
Yes,
but that's also because you can actually,
I can,
this is kind of a fucked up story,
but I might as well talk about it.
The real reason I have fucked up,
uh,
I have trouble fidget,
which you already know about was,
and this is a bad story.
Um,
but in college I,
this is real and I'm not saying women this overall,
I'm just saying this happened to me.
I went to school in the south,
um,
and I in Nashville,
Tennessee and went to school at Vanderbilt and I should the brain,
Jesus,
thank you.
Look at our biggest headache.
Well,
they let use the intelligence,
um,
English major.
But Anyway,
um,
I d I would date Christian women for the first time cause I was like that lively
Jew that they could,
you know,
it's like the college experience was dating a Jew,
but it was a little dangerous.
I actually have a cat named Shiksa.
Um,
but anyway,
uh,
fucking gay boys.
I loved it.
I mean,
it was,
it really is like a Jewish dream because it,
because,
and this is horrible,
but it just sort of feels like you're like,
they're going against Christ to fuck you.
Like that's such a compliment.
They're risking.
Yeah.
But I mean,
they don't think about that.
You know what I mean?
And it's,
um,
it just feels like they're making they're sinning and it's like a huge
compliment.
But anyway,
I dated someone who was very like very Christian and it was very interesting at
first,
very opposites attract.
But then I,
I caught her cheating on me with a guy who wore a hemp necklace of the pope to
his job at Starbucks.
So,
so while we were,
it was so specific and he thought the world was going to end.
It was crazy.
He was crazy.
But anyway,
it caught them.
I accidentally saw an email that confirmed it,
but it was,
and she admitted to it.
But what was interesting was then we,
I like that I would like take Valium and get blackout drunk because I was so,
it was the first time we've ever been cheated on.
It's a hard,
it's hard when you're like,
oh the world is bad,
that's bad.
Um,
before you even understand sex,
confusing,
whatever.
But at that point I was like,
my world was shattered and we,
we,
she then went off birth control,
snuck into my room,
woke me up,
we had sex one night,
which is essentially a version of assault,
but she also had gotten up birth control to try and get pregnant.
And then for several weeks,
um,
this is actually helpful for me.
I'm sorry.
Sorry man.
But for several weeks she was like,
I think I'm pregnant.
Should try to keep me.
Oh my God.
Cause she wanted to keep me and then she wasn't pregnant and I never,
and so it was then,
but I have not been able to finish during sex since then.
Sit Horse College,
except very few times in my life.
But it's been a nightmare.
So it is a little tragic.
And it's been about 15 years,
but at least I don't have any kids.
I don't want yet.
You got to talk to him.
Literally.
You got to talk to Josh.
He works here.
Uh,
comic.
Hilarious dude.
And uh,
he can't finish.
It's hard man.
It's a lot of work.
It sounds like yours is trauma related is
that you can work out with a shrink.
I think I need to go to one of those sex therapists like Helen Hunt played,
you know,
when they like have sex with you.
And they were like,
now like obviously your girlfriend would know this story,
right?
You told me the story.
I've told her and then she tried.
Did she try then we'll never have sex with that girl.
Crazy.
Does she try though to be like,
let's,
let's try to make a hat.
Many girlfriends have tried.
It's just a very frustrating thing cause you're like,
you just,
you feel a little humiliated,
you know,
but not like,
you
also don't want your girlfriend to think it's her fault.
Yeah.
You do.
If you were hotter,
well,
weird sort of thing where it's like it's kind of,
yeah,
it's just confusing and I don't exactly know what to do.
Like I don't even,
I don't even really know how to deal with it cause it's like I've slept with so
many people like it because also when you go through sexual trauma,
you can go different ways.
You could either never have sex or you could have sex with everyone and this
associate any feelings from it.
So I've kinda gotten that path in my life.
I mean,
I've also had girlfriends,
but like,
just lost my mind with it.
But it doesn't really,
it's all just to avoid feeling.
So yeah,
I have,
it's really fascinating.
I have the opposite problem.
My Dick is always rock hard and I can't stop coming.
I'm coming right now.
I've got a diaper on
one of our daughters is a problem.
I just said,
does he want to chime in on it?
I don't know.
Does he want to show us his dick?
I mean,
I'd love to show us
Josh,
you think you could,
uh,
maybe Josh relate to what's going on here,
man.
She was bleeding a little bit more.
[inaudible]
oh man.
I mean it's,
it,
does it feel good though to hear a,
uh,
you know,
like do you have a brother is here?
Yeah.
And you nailed it too.
Like how you can either just fuck nothing for awhile and that's no good.
Or you can just fuck everything and then that's pretty cool.
But it's like,
it's not though.
It's not your right if you become dead behind the eyes.
It's just a,
it's like,
what am I doing?
You end up in just so many places where you're like,
why am I here?
Like this is dangerous.
I shouldn't be in this.
I think we may have done something pretty unhealthy.
What's the over Josh?
No,
no,
no.
Don't call out there.
She was like,
I dare you to make Josh
and there,
there's some women with blonde that's a limited series.
Netflix,
you can sell Jerry to make judge cut.
We are a,
we are constantly adding cities to the,
Make Josh come to her
20,
20.
Hopefully.
So,
I mean,
I wonder if there's any,
I mean you guys obviously should be in a support group together,
but I wonder if there's any,
um,
like anything that they could,
uh,
may I ask a question that maybe you relate these,
when you are in the act of sex,
do you ever just find your,
call it the act of sex?
I just figured out your problem.
I guess that's true,
but do you ever just,
are you ever just not even there?
You know what I mean?
Like,
well,
yeah,
I mean,
of course,
because part of the problem is if you're so worried about coming because you're
afraid what it'll lead to.
Cause it's not just the leading to a baby,
even if the person's on birth control,
it's a little irrational.
You know what I mean?
Like even if like I have an Iud,
it's still a little rational.
It's the loss of control.
So I feel like you can't really get lost in sex because you're just worried
about what might happen.
So you can't,
you're not really feeling like the fact that you're in a magnificent vagina,
like it's an amazing,
let you do this.
This is the best,
this is the best thing.
Life can really effect element.
So it is and so and so it's a little Shim because you can't relax because you're
worried something bad's going to happen.
It's complicated.
It's really,
it's a shame.
So Josh,
having listened to this,
do you think that maybe your problem might be trauma related?
Like to,
can you think back to an incident?
I can't think of one that would be a trauma instance,
but I do know what you're saying.
Like,
and then there's also like say it's not a magnificent vagina and you get in
there.
My point was that they're all run of the mill.
I mean that's very nice of you to say you get in one where you're like,
this is not magnet.
Then you know right away you're like,
well this isn't going to happen.
And then it's just like a whole to do.
Trying to get out of it.
I guess saving face,
we even threw around the idea with Joshua.
He's like,
he's like,
maybe it would happen.
And again this could be very callous and not accurate.
Maybe he would be able to,
if it was like a total 10 like a smoke show,
well it won't hurt to try as all I said,
it won't know why not.
I mean we might as well try this.
I do think it is helpful to talk about this cause I'll bet way more med
experiences.
Oh I know that it's terrifying to talking about herself.
Uh,
Josh told me about it.
I've met at least a handful of people to maybe respond on Twitter to talk about
your sort of lack of coming and maybe it will reduce the shame for the men going
through it.
If anybody can relate to coming constantly.
I was like too many a DM and email from people by the way.
And I'm sure you've heard these advices to where they say like it's the way
you're jerking off or don't jerk off or don't look at porn.
These things don't work.
Right.
You've experienced times when I've,
cause obviously porn is very attractive because it's like you come,
it's like a simulation of sex but you're not having it.
But you still come and it feels better when you're watching porn a lot of the
time.
But it's not,
that's only helped a little bit sometimes just in terms of sensitivity,
but it's,
it's not the answer.
It's something else.
If he won't get it.
People have been messaging in,
here's one,
I don't know it's for Josh,
but maybe Jake and uh,
somebody wrote in,
I think I have a solution to Josh is come conundrum.
It's well documented that only Josh can make Josh come my solution simply put a
mask of job
hot white trash come down,
which happens to be with his cock.
We'll be able to tell the difference.
I believe that tricking Josh his penis into believing that Josh is the only one
involved.
We'll allow for that big release.
We're all anxiously waiting for it to the next time that Josh has penis is too
smart for that.
I don't know.
Maybe it isn't.
Well,
I think that's a great way for everyone to come.
Frankly.
I don't think it's just mass.
That's how you have to prove you love yourself.
I think it's a pretty good idea.
Josh mask.
But Josh come mask.
That's a great,
make the loved one come in your life.
Terrifying.
God.
All right,
well this is,
thank you for your insight.
Yeah,
yeah.
Thank you very much.
That that is fascinating that we have another guest and now it seems to be
calming.
It is coming up a lot.
I find that luckily any problem you have,
there's a forum for it.
You know,
like it's so,
it's like you're not like,
every time I feel like a fucking Weirdo,
it's like if I just tweet it out,
they're like,
oh no,
I've been through that.
You know,
so that's good.
Are also terrible because everyone's in pain,
but at least you're not alone.
You're not.
I do feel lucky to have grown up,
uh,
like pornography was not what it was,
what I was a kid or Internet access is the big problem.
I feel lucky you have kids.
Are they superior to watch it?
I'm giving them my passwords and stuff and he's like,
oh,
I save it in my phone dead,
but I do feel like it would have ruined me.
Right.
If there's,
I feel like it's having mass effects on your expectations are just so high over
stimulating to actually see intercourse when you're too young should not be
seeing that shit.
You need to start slow load.
When my dad would give me like one,
like a few times a year he'd be like here's here's like a playboy or something
like that.
It was like whoa.
And I would like to keep it like in a,
in like this briefcase at the top of my closet and like,
and it was a joy so that every time I had to get it out to climb and like get it
and it was the best,
it was like it really meant a lot.
And those are pictures of like sable of the WWE,
you know,
like,
like lady,
I was like,
oh my God,
this is my late like it was meant so much.
And then you had to actually actively fantasize
photo.
Yeah,
habit,
take you somewhere.
But now it's like how many hundreds of thousands of videos.
And I was like,
what am I looking for?
Gaping buttholes and how many 50 guys coming in one woman's face.
I love that.
But yeah.
Is that your favorite?
Favorite,
the word,
if it's 49 it's not enough.
I used to print jpegs off of playboy.com awesome.
I once did it,
I,
the first time I tried it,
I went to playboy.com we had a family community,
family computer.
Oh my God.
So like by,
and by the way,
in early Internet two like I was,
I like prayed off of the fact that my mom didn't know what the Internet was,
so I could delete the search history and she'd be like weird.
All the internets or are all the websites are gone now it'd be like,
I dunno,
it's the mystery of the Internet.
All these computers are,
yeah.
But one time I went to a playboy.com found the perfect image and hit print and
it just didn't print.
And I was like,
oh,
well.
And then I just walked away.
And then a few hours later my mom showed up like shaking
with this image that it,
it had been put into like the printer like Q or something or was it like legs
spread
over the shoulder?
I have scoliosis and a sexy,
the playboy doesn't show,
oh they do like a lot of like Bush shots,
tasteful bushes,
penthouse and hustler
fingers inside
someplace they'd have like they have you like squirting at the camera.
Like it was crazy.
It goes something be like you'd be like mid,
mid,
mid.
It was just like,
Whoa,
what are we doing?
The hustle girls were like,
you ready to grow up?
Grown up stuff.
Yeah.
Babysitter ever.
The center fold.
And then did she give her likes and dislikes in the penthouse or hustler?
It wasn't like likes everything.
Yeah,
it was definitely like I dream about sex all day.
That was their thing.
I always try to put that that was the fantasy that the man wanted.
I'm insatiable course crazy where it's like every like the truth of adulthood is
like you have a headache.
You know what I mean?
Like,
even if you're like a headache and your stomach hurts because we had too much
lactose.
Yeah.
No one is like just goes man.
Knowing that person would be so annoying
if you're trying to have a family like the kids.
These kids,
fuck no,
he's insatiable.
So I wanted to show you something.
I love a visual.
Yes.
So we have this uh,
game we like to call horrible or hilarious and we just show you clips and you
tell us your honest take.
This is it hilarious.
Is it horrible?
Great.
All right,
here we go.
Good.
Kip.
One gentleman was leaving his house right heading out.
Wow.
Okay.
Well these two are mentally disturbed already.
Well,
I mean,
no,
this is classic is what is funny is this is what funny is.
Thank you.
The problem,
and this is one of the issues with human,
unless you just died.
Did we just want you to know he's getting up?
You guys did.
But here's the thing.
He let us laugh before he died and I think that's really the thing.
He didn't get up broken his neck and he's paralyzed.
He's paralyzed.
He didn't hit his head.
He did not hit his head.
So that's good.
Jake.
Jake's got back problems.
He left.
Yeah.
Okay.
You know what I love?
He's that guy that we talked about a couple of weeks ago.
It's snowing and he's wearing shorts.
There's always that,
hey,
this guy's always those east coast,
east coast asshole.
This is what's crazy about this is as like as comedians you're trying to like
write interesting things.
Nothing will be funnier than someone always funnier,
so hard at comedy and like this will always be,
it's always funnier by the way.
That's exactly what's,
uh,
what we see when,
you know,
when you have kids,
especially in cartoons,
just people fucking animal characters.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
When I was in high school,
my girlfriend was it dancer,
and not to Brag,
it's pretty fit,
but a one day,
one day after school,
um,
I was in the dance hall and uh,
I was like trying to dance moves that they were doing where you're like jumped
up on one foot sputter out Atlanta on the same foot.
And the first time I tried it,
I broke my ankle and it was one of the most like I the hardest.
I've tried not to cry at like tears streamed.
I like to run out of the fucking dance hall with a broken ankle.
Holy Shit.
Oh,
did that come off in a technical problem?
Why strong?
Wow,
this is good.
This is what I wanted.
But you feel like that
would work while you were inside?
I feel like that guys sound as he hit that ground.
It sounds a lot like,
nope.
What's up?
How are we?
Can't play it at blue band is telling us.
Okay,
what about this word
fix
now?
And that is weird.
That thing just came off.
Who Do you get
$3 million trouble?
Yeah.
Oh,
sponsors.
Sponsors get upset.
Oh,
and we play certain clips.
We had McDonald's sponsored this show.
We painted the set McDonald's colors per their request as part of the deal.
And we played that clip of Terry and they,
boy,
we played the video and we analyzed it,
puts a pup plug in and
they dropped out.
Mcdonald's didn't like that now.
And we did it on the first episode of their sponsorship.
Ah,
and you lost two point $3 million,
which was like the campaign man.
I'm so sorry.
We got a steak house arrest and then they fired us because of that clip.
You just want that clip.
So I keep going back to it now.
He's like,
maybe not such an artistic integrity.
You want them,
I'm not going to let somebody talk you out of what I believe.
I believe how military Terry and his butt plug reviews.
Wow.
He really tickled your fancy.
He really,
he really did cost us everything.
All right.
And your Lamborghini.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Anyway,
know what'd you guys get one?
No,
no.
I drove Subaru.
They come off again.
Yeah,
I think I got it.
Let me,
let me just hold it came off again.
Yeah.
I feel like something that allows me,
Eh,
no matter what,
if I'm able to achieve success,
I would like to always drive a Subaru.
So people like,
wow,
look how grounded he is.
You know what I mean?
Would you really do that?
I love,
it's a good ride,
but like even endless endless money,
you would just be like,
nope,
sticking to it.
It's just a good ride.
I guess.
When I think about endless money,
it's kind of hard to I you did that,
you know who did that like exactly what you're saying.
Is tosh really want to see,
does he drive like just super cool.
Zach Galifianakis drive like a Prius.
He drives like an old ass man.
What you,
what do you guys drive?
Cause you guys are killing it on cheap.
I like Jeep Cherokee.
I just don't have much of a neat,
like I don't,
I feel like I would look terrible in any card that people would be like,
that's a good call.
I'd be like,
look,
there's a producer that's in your head.
Oh,
okay.
And the experiences,
it's too fun.
It feels great.
Of course it doesn't matter.
Not a car guy.
It does.
That's very fine when you have kids now.
But like what are some dumb shit you spend money on that you have a decent
amount of money.
Like what are you doing?
Let's talk about it.
This guy wants a gold chain.
Oh yeah,
of course.
40 in a couple,
let's say cane.
It could say that.
Yeah.
Or,
yeah.
um,
I feel like,
I thought I told her I was,
I'm turning 40,
we should celebrate.
All I'm asking you for is get me a chain with a medallion,
lots of diamonds,
and then there's no resale value in jewel.
What's the sell it kind of way someone's gonna fucking jacket.
Where here brother,
not to fucking,
what's his name?
When he was in his way,
he got the grill.
That's true.
Danny Brown was,
oh really?
And He,
yeah,
he was here a few weeks ago.
He was like,
don't do it.
It's like,
are you talking about,
oh,
cause it was like,
Nah.
He's like,
I've made a lot of dumb purchases.
And he said he brought like he bought a Cape
and uh,
like it when it was like couture,
you know,
early on that.
But I feel like it's fun just to buy a couple of dumb things.
Right?
Yeah.
No,
nothing.
Did you spend your money on anything stupid?
Nothing.
Not really.
Only mattered even know what I,
I think I was still afraid it's not going to continue.
Yeah.
So I'm,
I'm afraid.
You know what I mean?
But I feel like I'd love to spend something,
I,
I'd love to buy something fucking dumb.
I get like poke a bowls.
Bowls.
It's just like tuna.
Oh yeah.
Those are really good buddies with j Hawk who played in the NFL for 10 seasons.
Yeah.
I'm like,
Yo,
like tell me like,
what do you spend?
What's some like,
you know,
not necessary expenses like shit you bought.
He was like,
oh,
like I'll,
I'll just buy like mulch from my yard.
He's like,
I invested intelligently and then he goes,
one,
one summer we rented a house on this lake.
I'm like,
yeah.
He's like,
so that's one.
Are you serious?
10 Nfl seasons?
He was like,
yeah.
He's like,
I'll just order shit on him.
That SmartVault one.
Yeah,
of course it is.
No,
it's like,
tell me something reckless and stupid,
but I agree with the,
the thrill for me is going to,
you know,
trade.
There was Joe and just buying what I want.
I think that is what success is,
is if you get the bill at dinner,
not even looking at what it is like just be like,
here you go,
here's the card.
I think that's what success is.
It's just literally like here you go.
I don't have to worry about money.
Yeah,
I'm saying to make crazy purchases,
but it is fun for stories
like I love to hear your story.
You could spend a chain into gold like you could like you could like make it a
thing you put on your next special.
You would probably make money off of you just to find money.
So maybe what I should do is write it off,
tell production that I need this,
don't pay for it or have someone donate a listener,
write a bit about it.
Go Fund me.
There you go.
Fund me for you to how much hatred I would get.
Or like you're having us by one.
I just want to $40,000 challenge your problem.
Is that what it would cost?
Is that what you're thinking?
Damn,
that's crazy.
Just a bunch of diamonds.
I hate spending money on jewelry.
I think it's the worst
sneakers,
like really high end Bart Scott on that.
There's that a documentary broke,
it's called oh the the 30 for 30 yeah,
the 30 for 30 and he was like,
I bought a wolf coat.
Most depressing things I've ever seen in my life.
It's just about how like overwhelmingly almost all NFL players in a lot of other
like are broke within five years of being.
But the worst part was like how
they were saying in that documentary they're saying like on payday,
um,
cause like I guess NFL checks at least 20 now it's probably all direct deposit.
Right.
But it used to be like checks and players are saying they would go into the
player parking lot and family and friends would be waiting in the player parking
lot.
Oh.
Like it was like everybody's pay day.
Oh Damn,
that's fucked up.
I mostly just don't want to think about money.
That's like,
that's the way I want to be.
It is.
We're like,
yeah,
walk into trader Joe's and it's like,
I'll get the chocolate covered pretzels,
those walk way for cleavers the chocolate one.
This is,
I think,
I don't know,
it's embarrassing,
but it's Kinda true where like I've gotten into trader Joe's and been like,
I want to get like good wine and just
sort of the trashcan.
No,
do saw that.
Like all the prices are so cheap.
And I'm like,
do you have anything more expensive?
And uh,
and then,
but like,
I don't know what I'm talking about with wine.
I'm just trying to buy a more expensive one.
And they're like,
well this is a great deal.
I'm like,
I don't want a great deal.
Do you have anything like $30?
But everything's like four 99 and uh,
I dunno.
I feel like it,
they'd be lucky with wine cause you,
I don't know what the fuck.
So it doesn't,
whether it's $200 or nothing.
Do you guys read that?
Uh,
there's this book about this guy.
I think there's a documentary called sour grapes or this guy conned the like
high end wine industry because it turns out none of them know what they're
[inaudible] me like frauds.
Yeah.
Such a good,
this is a movie.
Yeah.
There's a documentary about,
and there's a book the,
the documentary's called sour grapes and he basically like learn how to fake
labels from like Bordeaux,
you know what I mean?
And was like in selling it to the richest motherfuckers in the country.
And I could go to like trader Joe's and combine cheap wines,
taste expensive cause he had a good Palette and the FBI fucking got him and he
was,
he'd sell them for like tens of thousands of dollars.
It's like $4.
And he got away.
He got away with it for years.
He like con,
like all these rich white men.
I just saw one on
the minutes,
which is not a con,
that's like the spin on it where there's this guy who was in Michigan and he
went into a liquor store to,
and uh,
he had just retired and found the,
uh,
a lottery game.
I forget what it's called,
like windfall or something like that.
And it was just like a,
a math equation that he did in his head.
It was like if you get all five numbers,
you win.
But if you get four of the five,
you still get some amount and if you get three of the lesser amount.
Yeah.
And he said like in a minute,
he was like,
oh,
so I could definitely win money every time if I buy enough of these.
So then he just started doing that and it just grew and grew and grew and grew.
And so eventually he won a total of like 26 million doing this.
And like then getting like a pool it by getting friends to watch go.
Then Michigan shut it down.
They were just like,
we're done doing the same.
And then Pennsylvania was like,
well you can do it here.
So then he just started driving out there to play it.
And then eventually,
you know,
FBI starts going like,
Hey,
this one guy has won this game like 150 times.
So they launched an investigation.
They're like,
yeah,
he just solved a math equation.
So there was no,
and I wish I would stumble on some shit that,
oh my God,
it makes me,
I was like,
fuck.
He just,
he just kept just,
he was like,
and then he goes in the air and he's like,
I just can't believe
who else can do this kind of math.
He's like,
he's like,
it's a simple equation.
It does feel you do have to work really hard.
I mean,
comedy,
you don't have to worry.
Yeah.
No,
you have to work really hard.
You have to work really hard.
It's like a great way to make a living.
But I would love to just win the lottery.
I would not be fun.
No pressure.
Yeah.
Like you just go like,
oh,
I mean I do it,
but yeah,
all my bills.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter.
Lottery covers my bills
in your pocket.
My pocket.
I keep a Dildo in my pocket.
Yeah.
What's it for?
Um,
chair squeaking.
It's your chair squeaks when you,
if that's the sound,
the keys jangling or something.
Okay.
Guys know each other.
Dad and mom.
Mommy and dad?
Well,
not,
not daddy.
Yeah.
Sometimes with the kids around Mommy,
we call her mommy.
That's how I see it on the show.
Oh,
homies,
are you going to have kids?
What's going on?
I don't know.
It feels like one of those things where like I'm like,
I dunno,
and then cut to five years,
I'm like desperately tried to have a kid.
I don't know.
I just feel like my kid will be fucking crazy.
So I don't know if that's exciting.
I mean,
I,
the thing is you have with,
with Comedians,
like most comedians I know,
like they're getting to the age where they're like going to or having kids or,
and it's like the,
some of these people,
the way that I know them,
it's crazy to me,
they're reproducing like,
it's like really scary.
I know what it's like,
but it almost just feels inevitable for everyone.
So I feel like saying I'm not going to do it is dumb,
but I don't want one because I'm selfish.
Oh,
that's good to know.
But I mean,
don't,
were you selfish?
What were you not selfish before?
Like selfish?
Yeah,
yeah.
You are.
I think because I like grew up in a house where it was such a priority,
I guess family,
I always thought it was just like automated.
The only thing that kept me from like really actively pushing for kids a while
ago.
You're fun.
MMM.
The only thing that kept me from doing it earlier was just that I was like
broke.
Uh Huh.
Or pushing for that and I didn't want to do it yet,
but I would have found another one.
Right.
But when you guys met,
you were like one of the for you talked about it like you both want kids?
No,
actually when we got married I was terrified of it and um,
it was something I thought I possibly could do,
but I was like,
I'm scared and my family's crazy.
I don't know if I could do it.
And then I got into therapy for a long time and then,
yeah,
through therapy I,
I,
you know,
figured it out and now I love it.
It's the best thing ever.
Now I'm really into family stuff,
but I never thought I would be.
It's true.
She was like,
like when I was like,
we were about to get married,
I was like,
you want to have kids?
Right.
And she was like,
when I was like,
I don't know,
she was like,
are you out of your fucking mind are so broke when we got married,
I mean we were,
we were living in the rampart division like Macarthur Park
and she was like,
do you want to have a kid here featuring on the road?
And like,
no,
you're losing money basically.
And then I remember right,
like right,
right after we got married,
like the week after I got a call that I booked like 12 headline weeks at the end
props and it was such bottom barrel pay that I did like all of those,
they were almost all in a row and then immediately had to go get a job.
Yeah.
I was like,
it really make you want it.
Yeah.
Do you feel one of the concern about having kids is,
um,
although like you have to like go to the kids' schools and like talk to the
parents and like engage in more bullshit.
Like that is one thing is you have to be like,
yeah,
your kids call to come over for a play date.
Like,
yeah,
Pta,
oh my God,
fundraiser shit.
Yeah.
Can you kind of can't be fully human?
It feels like,
well that's my concern on now.
Our children are not school age yet.
We have one kid in like a preschool thing and I dread it.
I do the bare minimum every time I come home they're like,
do you want to sign up for this Emily?
I don't want to sign up for shit.
Don't,
I'm not that mom.
I'm not going to bring stuck in homemade cupcakes.
Like what's the bare minimum for my son to participate?
I remember like it.
They're like,
so you're coming Saturday and I was like,
toilet.
And they were like,
uh,
the like were doing the dance.
I was like the dance.
Like whoa,
he's been rehearsing.
I was like,
he's three.
He doesn't mention it to shit.
And then they're like,
well,
do you want to,
are you going to go?
And I was like,
I don't think so.
She was like,
they're all like,
they've been rehearsing and I was like,
yeah,
my wife's out of town so I can't really do it.
Yeah.
You also have a few more years before not going to things has an effect on them.
You know what I mean?
You could not go to things right now,
but when he gets to their playing like soccer or they're playing the flute or
something,
if you don't go,
it's like my dad doesn't look,
that's fine.
That's the problem.
I played drums and percussion and uh,
in grade school about to turn everyone on immediately.
I know that everyone just got,
but that's the other hell is like,
what did they start playing an instrument and you have to listen to them suck
instrument
drums,
piano.
That's just in the background is I do a team sport.
Like what you were talking about
was
what if it's a sport you don't like?
I remember my sports,
I like tennis.
For me,
I was like always like objects,
so excited about sports.
And I remember one of my friends,
this is like 10 years ago,
so way before I had kids.
I was like,
Oh,
you're having a son,
man,
are you excited about sports?
He was like,
Yo,
I can't wait to get them into baseball.
And I go,
what if he doesn't like baseball?
He's like,
Oh,
like what?
I'm like,
what is he like soccer?
He goes,
well I won't go to the Games but I'll support them.
And I was like,
you won't go to the gay.
And he was like,
I don't like soccer but it's your kid.
And then now I'm like,
Oh yeah,
I'm not really into baseball.
I just hope you like something,
you know?
Well
just start,
just start putting football on all the time and it'll just be a part of it.
You're brainwashing him and put,
put the posters up in the fuck doesn't room and does it feel that way?
You're like,
we're brainwashing our kids.
Totally.
Yeah.
And you're just choosing,
cause you're just exposing them to things.
Like my three year old will say,
well he'll mention football.
And I'm like,
that's because of do you work?
Like how do you feel in terms of like them having certain Polish like political
opinions or religious opinions?
Like are you like,
you can't do that or you'd like,
are you going to be like,
do whatever you want and you're making,
okay.
Okay.
Yeah.
How's it feel like,
you know,
the older you get,
even with without kids,
but with kids,
I think you,
you start to see,
you know,
young people really passionate about something that in your mind you're like,
they don't know what the fuck there.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
And I think the older you get,
the less it stresses you out.
So I'll be like,
oh,
that is interesting.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We're going to go march.
That's good.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I think I'll totally be like,
gotcha.
Yeah.
But I like that sort of antisocial free thinking.
I try to cultivate that more than anything.
It's a little anti authority all like they don't know everything.
Don't listen to these fucking idiots.
[inaudible] turn that on you.
It's fine.
It's okay.
Can I,
that is,
I've always wanted that,
cause there's a pair of like,
what's a,
at 1213 they're going to not like you anymore.
Luckily you guys are pretty,
like,
you have cooler jobs.
Theoretically,
they won't be cold then,
but like if you don't care,
they'll be like,
dad,
I watched your comedy.
It's,
oh you're going to hear,
hold on.
Yeah.
And everyone I talked to with kids that are older now,
like teenage kids 100% they're just like,
you're late to their,
to their dad.
And they're like,
you know who?
It's funny.
And they'll always mention someone who they're the guy,
Kevin Hart or something.
Let's just say someone super famous or someone who's like totally dead.
Right?
Yeah,
right.
Of course.
Right before you guys go to the,
I wanted to show you a couple more hilarious clips and just get your,
your reaction.
See if you think it's funny or not.
What the hell?
What has happened?
Ready?
I think he's fishing,
right?
Yeah.
And they look like shopping on Amazon or something.
[inaudible]
see I'm calling fake on this one.
I'm calling too.
I think that that was play cause nobody runs to help him fast enough.
Well he's,
he's helping them.
Yeah,
it does.
Does look painful and you see that I felt planned.
That's pretty good acting job.
I feel like,
you know,
get them on the show.
He really sold it.
Well,
I mean,
don't these guys know that you're going to get your Dick pinched eventually?
Dylan,
this for generations,
they have like a Dick Cover.
You know what I mean?
You're fishing in the Amazon.
Their tribal elders would be like,
but one thing to remember,
I mean that is Dick.
It is,
it is hard to look at something happening to dicker balls without feeling like
I'm covering myself right now.
I'm like literally went to start covering myself.
So maybe you just need to see guys coming more though.
I mean,
I have seen a lot of coming in my life.
It's usually on a face,
but it's a,
yeah.
Uh,
okay.
Let's see.
Is there another one?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Pinch Dyckman what do you think pinched his dick?
Was that like a,
it was like a crab crabs.
Yeah.
Nope.
Oh,
here we go.
This one?
Yeah.
Ah.
Oh.
It's a dirty Tampa called the dirty tampon.
Be real either cause I'd shake it.
That's why I gave you what,
three or four good seasons that was.
That was a Wolverine Wolverine movie that was like,
what?
What was that?
Where was that taking place?
I like,
do you want to taste the tuna?
That was a great line.
I love that.
I don't even know if that was horrible and hilarious.
That was just,
that was really impressive.
It's really just made me think differently about the world.
Well,
I'm impressed that she could take it
tampon out.
Um,
might've been,
it might've been like plan.
It doesn't feel like that was insane.
When you take a tampon out,
you have to be a little smaller.
Slower,
a little more deliberate.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It's not that quick of an endeavor.
I don't know.
I personally don't rip them out that fast.
I do have like vivid
visceral memories of the Times I've been hit the balls in my life though.
It really sticks with you.
Like what gets in your girl?
What?
It was 11 played soccer.
Yeah.
I remember a kid did a prank or like his setup.
I wasn't up in a like the community pool,
you know,
like at a public pool and this guy,
this kid,
we both like probably eight or nine,
uh,
standing in kind of the shallow end and he goes,
what's that like?
What's on your arm?
And I was like,
what?
And as he grabbed my arms and he kneed me in the class and I just collapsed
crying dodger that comes with that.
It's always supplies.
Yeah.
I was once on a school ride home from a band thing.
Again,
not to brag,
but I played percussion.
Okay.
And I was,
I was sleeping like this and I was,
I woke up to a guy who came up to me,
I'd like just from the back with a,
with like a mallet,
the back of the balls.
There was like a time during high school where it was funny to play the game
ball tap.
And it's like,
that's not a funny game that goes.
And the fast guys that it had,
the loose written,
I am not funny,
like a towel of a hand.
Like it's make it snap thing you gotta do to get your nuts.
Tap like that is really overreact.
I think you need to,
you need to carry a gun.
That's what guns are for.
I only want guns for ball taps.
Faults absent that.
Cool.
About half at all.
You getting furious or you get mad when the kid accidentally kicked her nights
and that's a,
that's a real,
by the way they stomp.
Oh,
I bet it makes you see white and you're just like,
oh fuck yeah.
I knew.
You know,
you can only hit him so hard.
No,
of course.
With your,
with your boss.
Do you guys have any live dates coming up?
Do you want to plug in?
If you want to check out?
I've run a show in Los Angeles called good heroin.
You did the first year anniversary,
but at the echo at a,
it's every Saturday at stories,
books and cafe and I,
my buddy Jeff stages did it.
Yeah.
He was just done.
It's really fucking fun and it's a good show.
Yeah.
Follow us on Instagram and Twitter.
Watch corporate corporate.
I think you guys will like this screen or season two.
Tuesdays at 10:30 PM yeah,
we got,
we got the full length,
all the shows.
Oh Shit.
Your watch as much as we want.
When I liked about your show is that it really captures the,
the horrible suck of corporate life.
Like,
Oh yeah.
It's so great.
We're so lucky.
We don't have to,
we only have to sell out to them.
We don't have to work at those offices.
No,
it's so great.
Yeah.
Congratulations on it.
Thank you guys.
Thank you guys again for Kevin.
Thanks for having us.
Thank you.
We'll be right back and we are back with a guy who just like a Jamaican has 11
job.
He,
he does it all.
Uh,
he also has a standing Tuesday appointment for right
haircut.
It's just like the gays.
Ah,
he's with us now.
It's our good friend Brendan Shop.
Hey,
thanks Jaime on wait,
what's about this hair cow?
What did you get my haircut.
Well I did,
I'm going out now cause Bradley Cooper inspired me and stars born.
I'm like look at his hair.
I'm growing.
My shit out here was fresh,
sexy,
so I'm like,
I'm going to grow mine out.
So you were just talking about today whether she would do like eat his bum and
not Bradley Cooper.
I would,
but she's already his bones.
She said Ryan Gosling or I ain't gon love Jake.
Gyllenhaal.
I like Jackie's talented.
Jake and Goslin aren't talented.
What?
Well,
no,
I'm sorry.
Not talented.
They're not,
they're super talented.
Correction.
They're not very manly.
Yeah.
Bradley Cooper's man.
But I have manly at home,
so when I eat out I want to eat all you want.
Right.
You want a twink on the side?
Yeah.
I want us different flavor.
Like how's your mom is manly all did.
So what if I want to eat butt hole?
I want to eat like a hairless clean.
Yeah.
Or if you want to go super different,
you just go black guy.
Yeah.
Now we're talking.
You go black girl.
Oh yeah,
I've done it.
So yeah.
Oh yeah.
We went to my first Laker game and I had a dream that night that was,
my mom had a big dog.
I had to put a bib around her neck.
She was just like salvage.
Yeah,
like a full record.
And she was like,
can we go to more Laker game?
And I was like,
you've never talked about love and basketball.
She's like,
but these guys are so,
so good at basketball.
I want to sit in that.
I want to sit in the Jack Nicholson seats so they're dogs can swing as they run
past me and I can really see the dealing with here.
I want get my face smacked by a dog.
That'll do it.
You sit Kate's court size,
you get some taking your face.
I'm fixated on them too.
Hey,
can I ask you?
So as an athlete,
Brennan,
how come they're dicks don't swing more as they're running their impressions
shorts now at that must make it pretty sweaty down there.
It gets pretty grimy.
I bet there's mistakes after a game,
but the whole shaft is tore up.
Tore out ass cracks guy.
Imagine eating that post game button.
No,
no shower.
No I would not.
But you could just stand
those guys.
Fuck so much
more than anyone else.
NBA guys,
first of all,
it's a great question.
First of all,
you're you're gifted physical specimen and in most in in reality these guys are
just larger human beings.
Then like 99.99999% of an average size basketball professors like six,
seven,
he's a fucking giant queue.
Some of these dudes,
six ten seven one two 60 to 300 black,
there's not,
and here's the thing,
you're paid out of your mind.
Guaranteed money.
Yeah.
You're a piece of shit that rides the bench.
You get like 9 million a year at least,
you know.
And then the ballers are so out of control ball and they're making like,
you know,
40 million guaranteed a year just playing and another 40 like do you guys make
100 million?
The other thing where everyone wants to suck them off,
your wants to suck him off cause the one of the only sports to where there's no
helmet protected,
there's nothing and there's only 11 of them per team and that's the NFL helmets
on.
There's 53 of them.
Like it was just my thing.
The culture of the NBA is dope.
It's run.
The culture is actually,
it's,
it's dictated by the players.
The players union is very strong and the culture is like,
it's us.
We're the best basketball players were the best 400 basketball players in the
world.
And we put on a show and they fucked and they,
fuck I update.
How about Tristan Thompson?
He's fucking everything.
Yeah.
Friends,
sisters,
moms.
He's a good looking dude.
And then whenever somebody,
yeah,
when someone's like,
what are you doing?
He's like,
I'm having,
I'm a ball.
Or what do we do my bed?
And then they'll be like,
the girls are like,
that's true.
Yeah.
It's all good though.
It's,
it is like you signed up for it.
Here's the thing,
if you,
if you marry or just our dating an NBA player and he ends up fucking around on
you and you pretend that you're surprised,
you're dumb.
You're dumb.
That's what happened with Kobe.
Kobe,
beef man.
Kobe beef and yeah,
her,
the ring.
And that was it.
That's kind of what you sign up for.
It is,
you know they're going to get sucked off on the road.
Yes.
That's part of the deal.
And they're now their hose are so different than other sports.
Their hose,
they have little ratchet bro.
Yeah,
they,
they know that they know the schedule.
They know the team hotels.
They wait at the hotel.
They know the spots.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's like high end lot lizards.
Yeah.
And they,
and they want to get pregnant of the original Jersey chasers,
but also there'll be one and then the whole starting five,
she'll suck the squad off.
That's what I'm talking about right there.
Now I just ran our producer,
our home,
no curfew for the NBA so those guys can stay out cause that's a huge problem.
He's like,
what am I supposed to fuck?
Yeah.
What are you talking about?
We're playing basketball.
The God damn time.
We got the fuck at night.
But you're getting like 20 year old boys with an incredible amount of money and
they don't have a curfew.
That's silly.
And all the Nike's they can handle.
Right.
And they,
but what,
they don't show up in time to go to bed to rest for the game.
So that's the thing is you have that,
you have that thing where first of all,
there are games you would watch if you really follow the NBA where you were like
these dudes stayed out late.
Last a motherfucker.
They me with baseball to the end hockey,
we'll get hammered.
But in,
in baseball and basketball,
he seasons are long.
Basketball starts in November and if you make it to the finals,
you're playing in June,
that's all long fucking all over.
And there's only a laugh enough them.
Yeah,
they get to know,
get the best hose and every city.
What about being a fighter?
Did you,
what?
What's the host situation?
Let's talk about the cage rat.
There's a few cage rats,
but it's not like the NBA because they know that you,
you know,
unless you're a Conor McGregor fricking Brock Lesnar,
you're getting probably paid the same that they are.
So it's not that flashy.
Right,
right.
The other thing is I find like in basketball,
you know,
win or lose,
they're like,
that is the shit.
I feel like there's this such an emotion attached to like a girl who's like,
I'm targeting this bad ass.
And then he lost it.
She's like,
where's the other guy kicked your ass?
You know,
like,
it's gonna be weird because you might lose a basketball game,
but you're still the man.
Like you're James Hart and you skill still scored 40 points,
right?
You're still getting sucked off,
flip in the air and dunk like,
yeah,
that was the sheer amount of loss.
But Bitch,
I'm talking about a DDA is I'm going to all star game in fighting.
It's like,
well,
no,
I got knocked out.
That dude's better.
You're the loser.
That's rough.
That's kind of cage rats don't like,
does she hang out after like,
it's all in the eyes,
right?
Don't you just fucking
k Trad
salivating like you a basketball game.
Did you have the pre fight?
Uh,
there's always been that thing about sex and you know,
a professional myth.
But I mean,
so night before plus nuts whenever you can.
Don't hold it in it's old school.
Would you take a cage right and the night before?
Uh,
yeah,
I would.
I'm not mad.
Yeah.
What do you call it?
What do you call comedy hose.
Chocolate fuckers.
All right.
Little old in it.
It is old,
but that's just,
it's something like my mom would say maybe,
I mean your mind eyes.
Mouth fuckers.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's an old saying,
but you're right.
You want to update it.
Let's up to you.
That's up to,
let's come up with something.
The three of us are creative.
What is a rat?
What is another word for Idaho?
Yeah.
We need a,
we need a little,
yeah.
Skank what's a new word for a slut?
Exactly.
Thought sled is such a timeless word.
Hooker.
Um,
let's see.
Mars finding hilarious horror.
Yeah.
I feel like we need some sort of animal attached to it.
Punch a punch line.
Hooker.
I don't know the hook.
Hucker and I know,
I'm trying to think of words for punching little cone.
Yeah.
By the time it will just look at submissions.
Don't worry about it.
So how do you know they're a cage?
Right?
So you're timing the eyes like you,
meaning you see the girl in the audience or this is a hub.
It's like in your locker.
You can get some laugh lizards.
You can get say half laugh lizard cage rats.
You can get some Jersey chasers.
The DMS man,
they was down at the ams is open.
They slide into your dms is what they say.
Right?
Slide it hard
wood in Vegas.
How see you there.
Well,
when I was fine,
I retired six years ago,
so dms really wasn't that big of a deal.
Right?
But even now if I go into a city,
you don't have a fiance or you want to city Fresno,
Sacramento.
Whenever I open my dabs tits.
Wow,
that's weird.
That doesn't happen.
It never happens to you.
Zero Shit Tom.
I get some cool guys.
This let them really cool guys.
We're going to do this.
Let's be in the circle of trust.
Nothing near good looking dude guys.
I get a lot of dudes.
Yeah,
of course.
Loads are just like I'm putting it out there.
A Guy,
I'll just be like,
I don't know.
And it's got like a,
you know,
it's like those guys had the same mentality that straight guys do.
Chasing tail right there.
Just like for it numbers game.
Maybe he'll bite.
Maybe it's feeling Kate sent shop a picture of my balls and then he didn't
respond.
I don't know.
Not a big deal.
Go to try.
So you get like tit,
tit picks.
Y'All get some weird shit man.
I'm sure your fiance does.
She know about them not to.
Doesn't check my phone.
I'm sure if she had her body is ridiculous.
I'm sure she gets some ridiculous dms.
Yeah.
Doesn't she wait?
She works in Sports,
right?
Do you use to Mama fulltime Mama?
Yeah,
but when she worked in sports athletes,
I'm talking you wrap up fucking
Trojan helmet.
Damn homie.
You know what this is.
This is a good time to bring this up.
So Josh Potter,
who's a great comedian,
who else works here with us doing the show?
He has a thing.
He has a,
he can't come during sex like he can.
He's a straight man.
Was He?
Yeah,
he fucks.
He's right there with the beer.
He fucks.
Okay.
He fucks the man with the glasses.
Yes.
As me.
Yeah,
he fucks.
Okay.
Fucks.
He can get latest from here.
He can get in there and he cannot finish.
So what we did is we put it out there.
We put it out there.
Hey,
help him come help Josh.
Josh,
Hey Josh,
come tour.
Is he single?
Yes.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Here's what's happening though.
Ever since.
Fuck yeah.
Ever since we put it out there,
these hoes started or listening.
Watch the show had been sending him messages like,
I'll make you come and all this shit.
I know some of them are.
I think he needs help in his dick.
In his,
yeah,
like so like,
cause my DM game or I don't know.
He told me some of his responses and I was like,
like where?
They're like,
Yo,
let me suck you off him.
Like that'd be fantastic.
Exactly.
That's me.
It'd be like Nido and I told her I go when Shabazz y'all go take,
take advice from the hill because I mean obviously you're a great,
podcasts are a great broadcaster you also played for,
I have a favorite,
uh,
okay.
Football team ever.
The buffalo bills anybody puts on the red,
white and blue is my hero.
So hold on here.
Single Josh.
The thing is is I played as many football games for the bills is youtube.
Let's relax there.
I mean you put on the helmet,
you're a hero to me.
So I mean,
I'm sure in a like high school and college and stuff,
I never had that athletes swag.
I mean,
I'm sure you were like ringing your dick out all the time
in rugby.
I guess like it was just so soggy constantly.
Like what's that?
What's that like?
Did you have your rebel?
He's not wrong.
Nasty.
You did.
Did you do well Tom?
No,
I was,
I wasn't up there.
She's better than him,
but I didn't feel like
I did all right.
I was not,
I was not prolific in any,
in any good looking Gal.
Christine,
I'm sure you did.
Well,
I could have,
but I was raised in an era where aids was a big thing and I was so afraid of
getting aids.
Just stuff that I was always real then.
Yeah.
So I'm kind of battled over.
Age was like a pop.
She's 53 67.
No,
but um,
you know what?
I'm built for marriage and monogamy.
I used to have long term boyfriends.
I wasn't a good dater.
I'm not a good hookup girl.
He was supposed to be my first one.
Nightstand.
This guy now look at it and now we're married.
I did,
I did throw it in a few and I,
and I did not date.
I just put it in a hose.
But I'm saying I didn't rack up crazy numbers.
Yeah.
So,
but now you're,
your number is pretty crazy.
Oh,
he's disgusting.
I bet it's pretty nice.
Yeah.
I can just tell by the way he sturdy.
Good.
Everybody.
I don't
know.
Triple digits some on there.
Ha.
I don't trip.
Okay.
Hit.
Let me ask you this.
Do you do those hours?
Do you know the names of every girl you ever slept with Lina?
She gave me shit for that.
She was like,
what are their names?
A hall like if so shop I will give you a $20 million.
You can name 25 of them.
Thank you.
Get him 50
ejaculated in me.
I know their name.
That's why I don't like the idea of some guy.
But not that you haven't lived?
No,
apparently not as nasty.
I think it's fucking gross.
Like I actually go like there was the one with the missing leg.
There was the fucking life short one.
There's the one at the beach,
like that's how I give him like kind of give them like a little nickname.
Right?
Like if I met her at pizza,
I'd be like Chicago pizza or you go like,
hey,
how many girls you sleep with that week and you're like,
oh,
there was Asia,
there was a Asian girl,
there was a redhead.
Saturday,
big tits.
There was the one that farted and here it's like nickname.
So wait,
let's go back to potter.
Potter's getting these offers and I don't think right closing the deal.
No.
We need to capitalize on this opportunity.
Maybe like his hitch.
Yes.
He's the big fat white dude.
James Keys.
Kevin James.
I'm will Smith.
There you go.
Yeah.
You got any like tips?
Like what,
what happened?
Okay,
so
give me an example cause you got to be more aggressive because they're obsolete
down for the clown.
So you don't need to tip around.
You don't need to jump in the fucking Jesus Damn Bro.
All that just Ryan hit it.
Mapper
pulling when she comes on.
Strong
strong back deck.
Wagga pig.
Here's what I'm saying.
Are you working with a,
I don't know that I got big Dick [inaudible] Dick over here.
You know what I'm saying?
No,
he's good man.
I'm okay.
Yeah,
I've seen it though.
So we toured a bunch.
So yeah,
like,
but let's say this chick's like,
oh,
I heard you a problem.
Uh,
you know,
I'd like to help you with that problem,
but I'm in Cleveland.
He should be like fucking talking about airfare,
right?
So she'd be like,
well,
if you have a,
if you're only getting a few,
and she's like,
well,
I'm in Cleveland then I don't know your financial situation.
But yeah,
maybe you fly around router,
but he goes on tour with you a lot of times.
Just give me a ton of fucking laugh lizards.
So don't,
don't,
don't waste your fucking miles on this hoe in Cleveland.
Start start DM in the skanks and the other cities so derogatory towards women
and it's fantastic.
Showtimes Mike,
you're fired.
Yes,
thank you.
What do you guys think of Giggle,
Gash,
giggle gas.
No gas,
no dashes too aggressive.
The next round out.
Huh?
I wonder why he can't get it girl.
[inaudible] cash whores,
right?
Well
that's what I love about 20 minutes to come up with that which is sitting on it
fucking dash these bitches.
Huh?
It's a violent giggle.
Gas Next Gash.
Right?
So I swing my ax newer fucking nobody wants to hear the word Gash.
So wait a minute,
let's hear it.
Okay,
so it starts out dog.
You so cute.
I'm sure you've got a girl at home,
but if you've ever,
if you're ever in STL and want someone to try to make you calm,
feel free to hit me up.
Only if you plan to keep it high and tight and calm.
When you poop though Bro.
Jesus Freak.
He's a big fan.
She's a big fan of the show.
She's just dropping fan references.
Take a poop when you call.
It's just a fan reference.
That doesn't mean shit.
Yeah,
I know,
I'm familiar with it.
Um,
I wouldn't waste my time again.
I want to waste my mouse but I'll respond back.
I when you know,
like what's good?
Let's do it.
Like when you think literally what's good,
let's do it.
Jobs thing is basically,
it's just for my direct be direct.
Like it's all straight up be direct cause they're,
cause you show you all the ones you don't need you to warm up.
There's no foreplay.
You're getting there.
It's fucking on like donkey Kong.
And I treated him like shit too.
Right?
Oh my God.
You know what man?
I just feel like I say like I
come get it bitch or something like that.
Right.
I want to do that.
Not a good idea.
No Bitch.
You know what?
Come get this deck,
which I would probably take that out of it,
you know,
hone your aura here with myself.
So you wouldn't say bitch.
No,
I wouldn't say bitch.
But a girl messages you,
let's say you're single and she's like,
yeah,
Hey,
uh,
Brendan,
I'd love to make you come.
When you're in Houston,
you're response is,
see a march.
All right.
There you good?
Okay,
perfect.
I'll hit you up when I'm in town.
That's good.
Paul,
I'll hit you up when I'm in town.
Is that a good response to this lady?
And then you,
then you call on the female way.
Let me know if you're an ally.
We need to start following up with that more.
That's better.
Okay.
I'm like,
I'm on the west coast cause here's the deal man.
You might get a hold of fly herself out
Thursday and she's like,
I got a ton of miles or my man's a pilot,
you know,
and can jump on that plane.
It feels like this whole thing is just elementary.
That's how he says the word.
You say that was it.
Alimentarius I said elementary,
elementary spent time in western New York.
You know we speak oddly,
right?
I mean you've talked to friends and he's trying to say elementary.
Elementary.
Yeah.
I can,
I said it wrong one time.
That's not,
I say it son,
Bro.
You've been saying it wrong for 34 years that one time.
Can you click it again?
Click any game?
That'd be so retarded.
Elementary,
yeah,
might be.
I don't think they see that.
I was just in Bali.
I wasn't,
not just but six months ago.
Then buffalo out the helium there.
They definitely don't say that.
Oh
now Josh has a special gift and all good from helion by the way.
We definitely,
we definitely,
let's,
let's try this tactic.
Be more direct route there already and you don't need to butter him up,
but also maybe take it down a notch.
I,
I get a creepy vibe a little bit.
Yeah,
I know.
That's just,
I mean we haven't gotten to know each other.
Obviously a creepy vibe is what I put off.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
I mean I get it.
You'll get to know me.
Hopefully sometime you'll,
you'll realize I'm not as creepy as I love.
That part's true.
Yeah,
that's true.
I totally get your first impressions.
Yeah,
there is.
Yeah.
The whole gas weaponize giggle.
Gushes yeah,
I think that's a winner still.
I really no,
nope.
That's not going to connect.
That's not,
that doesn't connect from it.
[inaudible]
it's another one.
Let's do some more cause I think that you need Brendan's,
I'm learning that my initial instincts of joy when I received tits in a DM or
something and going like,
Nido are awesome.
That's not good.
Right?
No.
Awesome is not sexy.
Right,
right,
right hand tastic no,
they don't want it.
You're not a fucking announcer.
Where the best met her tits without sounding like a nerd.
Uh,
you know,
it's easy because let's say you don't want to use words,
use emojis and all that.
The salivating mouth like,
oh,
here you go.
Or devil horns or the the heart eyes.
What about the,
or you can do or he can do the eggplant,
eggplant,
drip,
drip and then a mouth.
Yeah.
Yeah because call these are straight up.
Go speak their language.
Laugh lizards bro.
It's like hieroglyphics.
Shit.
Yeah,
but for the horse and if she,
if she leads with like a whole statement,
you can't treat her like,
like a treat her like you're a lady.
She wants you to treat it like a Ho she told you.
Right?
Right.
You don't want to send like a,
like you're my queen and be like,
oh no,
you don't say I'm your claim
noted Josh put it this way.
A lady like me that's got the husband and nice children,
like in a nice lady.
I would never send a DM like that in a million.
What's that?
Tickets are like,
Nah,
I'll suck your cock at any city.
I'll make you calm like it's never mama quality.
I got news for you,
Christina.
There's a few married ladies that'll disagree with you.
Girls like that.
Sure.
Shitty by Shitty moms.
You know the shitty kid.
Your kid goes to the classes and the poor dude.
I'm saying the nice girls,
the good girls,
they don't.
That's what you say.
Nice things to
ease.
Are you trying to get a wife for you?
Try and get sucked off.
No wife.
Then we're sticking to the game plan.
Wait,
we had the whole thing about vet.
Can you come in a mouth?
No.
Also it's harder.
A vagina.
Dot.
Fuck Dude.
It's sad.
It's not code set.
Breading.
I know.
To be possible for you to understand your Dick.
Just imagine like,
I guess the way for you to realize like have you ever had like a month where
you're just like got so much pussy where you're just like your eyes rolling in
the back of your head and you're just,
you're not even,
you're like,
did I leave the oven on and you don't even think about sex anyway?
You know what I'm saying?
That's the only way that like maybe you can relate to me.
I'm this level.
You know what I mean?
Like it's just like Thursday and I have another pussy on my deck.
Like I just don't like those days.
But you just can't come at all.
Right.
Well he had a girl.
I can do it himself.
He just can't finish in the garage.
Yeah.
It's never been inside of them when he's got to get involved.
Have you ever had a girlfriend?
Yeah,
Todd Todd,
Todd.
Me Yet.
Don't say I don't know why I said that.
Don't say today
he played for the bills.
I'm nervous too.
God Damn it.
I did not play for the bills squad.
I,
yeah,
I'm,
I plays make it.
Did you,
did you do preseason?
Yeah.
Dude,
that's fucking,
and then your mind training.
You got to set your standards higher man.
Not Jim Kelly over here.
Okay.
More.
I liked coming.
This can we do,
he just taught you,
you realize that Emoji Shit.
That's some real knowledge that your phone game pregame as really d says free
game.
Right?
You should charge for this shit.
That was pretty awesome.
I'm definitely going to go with emojis.
Emojis are great because they're vague yet still kind of decipher ball and she
can read into that.
She had pretty black and white letter read into it though.
Is there any no,
no emojis.
Well you know what they all stand for,
right?
So he felt an egg plant.
That's a dick.
You have a peach that's the ass and then there's one,
there's the watermarks that's come.
The mouth is you're coming into their mouth
learning area.
Just trying to drink the full eclipse moon.
That's like a cuckold one,
right?
Why?
I'm not sure what that is like.
Yeah,
that's weird bro.
Hey,
what?
You know how we talk and then he's like,
yeah,
what about the moon?
He struggles with this finishing Chang.
What about if,
what have you got?
What?
A few to double team though.
When you kind of show him like front and center with the man that would be,
don't like show him the ropes he gives up to my left side.
I feel like you'd have a mask on jacking off in the corner.
Yeah.
I wouldn't really have to sing his whole face right now because he's covered.
But if you guys could like high five over the girl and I would be like,
wait a go bro.
Cause I would be like more like,
I'd be like congratulating you because I'm sure you'd do a better job than me.
I'd be like,
get her dude.
You know what I'm saying?
You know if will Smith and Kevin Jamison and x rays
dude.
And then
then you would have,
you could do this thing where like you got like,
like Brendan would be a Banger and then your inner mountain and you go,
you know,
he played for the bills and she was like,
Hey,
I really like his neck so much bigger.
Right.
Yeah,
this is a good idea.
It's trying to help here,
man.
You know,
this has been very helpful.
I very much
hold on.
Do you have a type?
No,
but we do sweat.
Never kind of,
we do have this thing that we've been talking about where since he,
he hasn't been able to finish with a lady of any type.
We're thinking maybe because we were trying to figure out what the,
no,
I don't think he's gay.
Admit to that part.
I mean,
I'm opening up.
Maybe he just needs to be with like a smoke show,
like at 10.
You know what I mean?
You have to pay for that,
I think with him.
Oh,
let's get you a professional.
Is it that easy of a solution?
Who wants to start the Kickstarter fund?
I have one here.
I don't want to show the ladies nudes.
This is another,
I mean,
I've earned it,
man.
I've got some knowledge.
I would show you my mom's nudes for the bills.
You know what I mean?
Like,
so,
uh,
so this woman wrote,
I would absolutely love to be your calm sponsor.
I also never eat.
I chain smoke and nothing turns me on.
More than a good old child's murder.
Try it out.
And I was like,
okay.
I wrote I would be honored.
And then uh,
I ruined be honored.
What do you have the fourth grade teacher?
Did she say back?
She goes,
come to Ottawa on your come tour too far.
That's it.
And then she said,
uh,
come to like I said,
oh that sounds,
I said,
I'm super excited to come to Ottawa.
I'm trying to make myself look better.
Great coffee.
And she said,
I can't believe you are responding to me.
Lol.
I have to make this happen now.
And I was like,
then she sent nudes and are they good?
Yeah.
Well the fucking put them up dude.
I mean,
okay.
All right.
You can edit it out of the video.
Yeah,
you want the audience?
Are they good?
If they're,
if they're assholes shots.
I don't want to see it if that quote,
so I don't want to see that shit.
You were seeing her nudes?
No.
Oh God.
You guys need to start a soccer player.
Soccer player.
Her,
her nudes got leaked and they are so graphic.
She's opened up her ass asshole.
Really?
It's so disturbing guys.
You're not supposed to look,
but she's kind of like,
she's sexy,
but she's like the super aggressive goalie,
right?
Goalie.
Who got kicked out of the Olympics?
Yeah,
she's got to hardcore though.
She had asshole picks.
Should I bring them out to you?
Can we put them on the screen?
I mean,
they're in my phone.
I don't think that's possible.
I bet.
All right.
Yeah.
Let's see here.
Let me get a sexy pick and then the girl goes asshole,
like inside her asshole.
All right.
Maybe too much for me.
Yeah,
it does that.
Is that the line?
What's a sexy peg?
Oh,
this is the girl who was trying to fuck you.
Yeah.
Was one of them.
That's one of them.
Came all on brother.
Oh,
look at that reaction game on Bro.
There's a video of,
oh,
she's kissing.
Oh,
and she has a strap on.
Wait,
what?
What?
What are you waiting for?
Oh,
what are you doing?
Get to Ottawa now.
What are you?
Don't listen to any my advice.
Let's see.
Let me see.
Don't you have miles?
Yeah.
What is wrong with you?
How much is a ticket to he opened for you,
Tom?
I'm looking.
Oh Dude.
Oh my God.
You need a cover on your phone.
You psycho swiped her.
All right.
Let's see.
Again,
I'm sure you're super nice,
but the iPhone one's a creepy vibe,
bro.
That old iPhone ones,
it moves up with creepy vibe.
What are you waiting for at?
This girl's going to make you take your phone before you start fucking dude.
Dude,
you're crazy.
You got to go to auto zone.
Got at all.
No,
those are good.
She'll make you come.
Yeah.
Geez.
She has a beak on her though.
Yeah.
Well No,
it's all right to go down.
Um,
she's smart not to show her face.
So I mean like from a sending naked pictures perspective,
right?
I mean it's pretty incriminating.
Yeah.
Do you care?
Do you send you a text,
by the way?
Do you know?
Do you know what Potter's a intro is?
When we have him on the show to do a segment?
What is it?
It's this right here.
Zeb Him cried.
I thought that was him crying.
That's how we,
that's how we bring them on usually.
That's nice.
Yeah.
How long have you guys known each other?
I've known him for a number of years now.
Yeah.
We call him the cockroach.
Why he doesn't eat,
he doesn't sleep.
He can't come.
How old is cause he's not even a human.
He's a he's 19.
I am 33 33.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it doesn't sleep.
Oh Wow.
Wow.
Yeah.
Um,
hey,
I wanted to bring up the other thing,
uh,
native,
so yeah.
Yeah.
So,
so,
so for people that um,
don't know,
I had it,
we got a real big kick out of this and that was that.
Um,
a few months ago you tweeted out a picture of my barber.
Yes.
And you said you're here with Tom's twin dude.
Every time I see him I go,
you look like my friends say,
girl,
you looked at my friends,
the girl.
I thought you guys look identical now before you go bad on him.
You Ready?
Yeah.
So I think he passed away.
What I want to go get my haircut,
uh,
last week.
And there was like a huge picture up of him and they're like,
uh,
he had a heart attack and he's on life support and we're doing a go fund me.
And I was like,
I can blend.
I know before we go bad on him.
I wasn't gonna look bad on him.
I was just thinking,
you look anything like that.
I mean,
mine.
No,
I think he looks like he's out,
dude.
No,
he's Mexican is all right.
Well that's,
you know,
but yeah,
he had a heart attack and then there's the idea of some say that he wasn't doing
well,
they had a go fund me,
you know who's going to cut your hair now?
That's the real problem.
What does the caption say there?
What does it say?
Fun Fact.
Did you know my barber's Thompson grows Mexican brother?
Yeah.
So is that a bad thing?
Not at all.
No.
I just,
I thought he was like,
I got a laugh out of it and it goes my mind.
I was just a mean,
would you say has a joke up?
I felt like mine was more fun.
Years was fun.
And yours just like,
apparently Brent's been punched in the face so many times that recognize his
friends.
Yeah,
but which was a,
it was,
people laughed.
It was a fun,
I did it in jest.
I just thought maybe,
you know,
the CTE was making you not see my face dude.
He got up similar features.
Remind you my wife's not at all that the only similarity is the beard and even
that man's beard is so full and have the same eyes.
Absolutely not.
No this,
this,
this is nowhere near town.
It was apparently early in the morning cause I looked like death in that
picture.
You look handsome.
This hand,
the other gentleman's handsome,
but no,
but it got us,
I got our wheels turning.
Oh yeah.
How so?
Well we decided that we should pull out some of your twins.
What I look like.
Yeah.
So here's this guy you think.
I don't know.
See it at all that more like Morgan Freeman.
Then that guy,
that's terrible.
It's Vinny from Jersey shore did eat all the pizza and Jersey shore.
What happened?
You don't think you look like him at all?
Not even a little bit like facially,
a little bit and I don't know man.
I don't think so.
He's got tattoos.
I mean that's the thing.
Why do you post that picture?
A ketogenetic diet now and he's much skinnier before and after.
She says he's very,
he's really in good shape right now.
I guess.
Maybe I'll see you at all in that.
I mean,
not really,
man.
I guess we both have eyes and a nose.
All right.
And we're both white.
This one.
This next one.
That's all right bro.
You and I had a baby.
You don't think your hair and it looks like him.
My hair does,
but that's about it.
He looks more like you than me to eat.
Well,
he has your stare,
right?
Your pregame,
you're pre-fight stare across the ring.
The very full face.
Very similar.
God,
I don't see it there either.
I don't see it.
What else do you guys see?
You [inaudible] this right here.
Brow Rob Kardashian.
You don't see,
I guess if I all the fucking honey in the world.
What are you talking about?
It looks just like you.
That looks like you.
You don't see them.
You don't know.
I'm on this crazy diet now where I do no sugar,
no carbs.
Yeah.
For a while.
Ever since,
and you're,
you're right.
You're right.
When when he said a fat shaming works because the Tommy store keeps using this
picture of how things was so fast.
I said,
hey,
it looks like bird,
like I think you sent it to me.
He said,
on the comedy thing,
I was like,
oh my and my face looks like that and then since then I've been really,
I've been on [inaudible] now.
He was just here last week.
No,
he's back up getting fat.
Why?
Because he's on tour and he's just like Terrence himself.
Liz.
That's burnt though.
Bert skinning.
Would it be fun?
That's true.
Yeah.
No.
You need them to be like,
yeah,
it's birth three 2120 he's up.
He's up to,
like he said,
he was just at just under three,
right?
No Way.
Yeah.
What?
I huge man.
God Damn,
no,
you're bullshitting.
No hurts.
385 I'll show you a picture of Christ where we were just with him.
Wow.
How about this?
Does this look like you?
Oh man,
that that's your company store picture.
That's got me started.
And why does it keep using it?
I don't know.
They just pull whatever they can get I guess or the laugh track that keeps using
this one to mean a fucking turtleneck shirt.
This is last week.
I mean he's thick for sure,
but see it's not,
there's no way.
He's two 90 [inaudible] Instagram.
If you guys want to see put that picture doesn't really even show.
Yeah,
it's definitely not to need a profile pic to see how tall is he visit from your
buffalo bills this on the practice squad and it's probably less me doing work
there that's fucking chat about and isn't there.
We have a picture of him on the phone.
There's a picture of you that we got on the phone.
I don't want to pay.
It's the star from born this way.
How about the uh,
how about Oh finger.
Then what about your octagon picture there?
I went out.
I was at this fight.
I was,
this is the mitre on fight.
Oh,
I don't want to fire this.
This was what you did on this,
didn't you fight Mitro uh,
I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't want to know this.
I want nothing to do with
what's going through your mind right here.
I don't want it on there.
I slept in the back.
Sorry.
What were you saying Tom?
You look how to 80.
You look heavier in this picture.
You know he won this fight.
Is that right?
Yeah.
Yup.
Did you make out with any of the rat the cage rats?
I don't know what that is.
If that's not you,
that's your twin,
I guess,
Bro.
Cool.
Yeah.
I don't have any,
any shop look alikes and we got a batch of that's what you,
I don't know.
Apparently ones the line,
so that's good.
I just saw it.
I saw you.
Yeah.
I didn't see anything else hill.
That terrible story about that Barbara though.
Yeah,
man.
That's terrible.
And you were seeing that guy for a long time week?
Yeah.
For long stuff.
You still go to the same place?
What happened?
I moved though.
I haven't been there since.
That's too far right now.
I gotta find one around here.
Yeah.
Alright.
You know what good one.
If you like what I got going on or you do it yourself or really you pay someone?
I paid for one.
Yeah.
Well when he does it himself,
he can miss I fuck up.
Yeah.
And then you go like,
what am I doing?
Saving 30 bucks.
$30 come on.
I know.
Spend that on coffee.
Come on.
Yeah,
I'm growing my shit out like Bradley Cooper.
So wait,
you do look thinned out though.
How long have you been doing this for days now.
Four days.
That's it.
Four days of super strict.
When we are moving,
it's hard for me to stick to my diet and work out.
Cool.
Are you going to have a cutoff point or he's trying to get like super,
super trying to get healthy.
I think you're going to be a really lean,
better leaner for sure.
I don't want my face to look like I fucking got stung by all the bs.
And that's your thing,
right?
Aren't you the Bee Guy?
Well The pee guy,
the like I guess the name,
the steam comes from like I get stung by a bunch of bs.
That's what I'm saying.
Yes.
But that's all right.
But you don't like it.
It's got the name of your podcast king in the sting.
I thought it was the thing in the ring.
No,
it's the king and the sting and then there's the fight and the kid.
But I don't fight anymore.
But that you stick with it.
You know what I'm saying?
So you're the,
you're the sting on the,
on the yes thing.
You're the states,
the king in this thing.
So feel,
thinks you guys don't like them by the way.
Why?
I don't know.
He's like,
how's it?
He was like,
cause we got done doing the show today.
He's like,
what are you doing?
And I feel to show before that for showtime.
One of your nine shows.
Yes.
And he's like,
where you going?
I'm like,
I'm going to do your mom's house with,
with Tom Christina.
He's like,
ah.
I'm like,
have you done it before?
I love them.
He's like,
nope,
they don't invite me,
man.
He's like,
I don't think they liked me.
I think that from a road rules alarm.
Are you kidding?
I didn't know you were on there.
Yeah,
she was on different season season right before Theo and I met him like in the
nineties dude.
And I have known that guy for a long time.
Just didn't do it for a hot second.
Like we're at the comedy store tonight.
People were coming up to us saying stuff.
I'm like,
Dude,
look at his manic crazy and these crazy,
that's crazy family here.
And he goes,
dude,
I've been doing,
cause I,
you know,
I don't feel for whatever,
two,
three years now.
I was like,
damn,
they crazy.
We'll start the same thing.
He's like,
dude,
I've been doing comedy for 14 years.
He said that I forget.
I forget.
I like,
I,
I don't know,
I forgot how long he's been doing it.
I should like look at us doing it,
man.
And he's like,
what are you talking about?
Hey,
did we mention the Fart Mike?
No,
people fart in that mic.
Absolutely do.
Oh Wow.
So if you have a fight,
this is where he got it.
He's on a diet.
Sure.
Everyone get Pinkeye.
Yeah.
I don't want to touch that.
If you're on the heat agentic diet.
Carb.
Yeah.
Dude,
you shouldn't hurt what big daddy Kane did and that thing.
Oh my God.
He can fart as good as he wraps.
It's amazing.
Oh Wow.
And he just got that thing of ripped into it and it was,
it was on rhythm.
It was like,
oh wow.
Good for him.
Zan Ku chicken for us so that we get gassy.
So you'd get going?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
I'll,
you know,
probably.
Yeah,
please do.
And please don't be like,
oh,
I forgot to mention it.
Okay.
I'll see what I can do it in front of your lady.
Nope.
Keep it sexy.
Wow.
Do keep it.
Sex is never forgotten for the any of my girlfriends or nothing.
What are you doing?
You have to make,
Brown would have to take a shit.
Yeah.
Uh,
just go Mosey around the,
tell her I gotta take a shit.
Oh,
do you have a separate,
like a secret?
Yeah,
I have.
I have my spots disappear.
Just disappear.
Yeah.
Mm hmm.
Interesting.
I've noticed that you have a nice piece of jewelry.
My husband wants me to buy him a chain for his 40th birthday.
He had a chain.
It's like a dope with a Cuban link route.
Are you being serious?
Yeah.
What about some black?
Oh
yeah.
Oh my God.
This is perfect.
When did you get it?
Uh,
I got it when I shot my special.
Gave it to,
yeah.
Who gave it to you?
This guy.
His name's chase chase Gregory.
He does all the,
the Dodgers.
Come on man.
I bought this piece from this Hans,
uh,
and then uh,
I was a camp or he talked to me.
He goes,
why aren't you getting ready to shoot your special ed?
Yeah.
It was like got some free and then drop that off.
Wait,
he just gave it to you,
had you,
yeah.
You'd bought things for him before?
Yeah.
I brought my girls running from him.
Oh,
okay.
That's really good.
Awesome.
Manifold chain.
It's still looks dope.
It looks real nice.
I'm trying to convince her time is maybe if he got off of her free.
I don't want to spend like 50 grand on a chain.
I think that's how it's like spend 40.
What's your like get 44 44,000 for every year.
Dope.
Still?
Where'd the rest of the show?
Okay.
You wanna try this one on too?
Yeah.
May as well rose gold and diamonds.
No wait,
what's the deal with this one?
You bought it from the same guy.
Same Guy.
Can you grab it?
Let me see it first.
Wow.
This is heavy.
Holy.
I'm talking about it.
Got You.
Doug.
He's already,
he's living my dream.
You can't let me go with dream.
It's up the chain smells like Brandon smell.
It sounds like your Cologne dude.
Yeah,
I wear that.
I go to bed in that gold hole when uh,
things,
kind of a good luck charm.
My son had his seizures.
I've got that like this.
The day when we figured out CBD oil gets rid of them.
So I haven't taken it off since he was not anymore.
Thanks to CBD oil.
Really?
What was wrong?
Real Story.
What was causing it?
Um,
they don't know.
It's epileptic seizures,
but the nine though,
and then,
uh,
there's like all like doctors like,
oh,
let's put him on some medication.
Let's do this,
let's do this.
And then,
uh,
I wonder these forums and the mom's like,
do not give a medication.
It fucks up everything you're doing.
Try CBD oil.
And I have some friends who know some people in CBD oil business,
so I'm like,
I'm going to try that before I try anything else?
Tried it.
Hasn't had one since dude.
And I got that chain when we figured out that the CBD oil,
I'll fix it.
So hello,
how are you feeling right now?
Look,
look.
No,
it looks,
I like the hand.
Hamsa,
is that what you call that?
A hand?
I like that wards off evil spirits.
Yeah,
I liked it.
I liked the shine Jewish and Muslim.
Yeah,
I like that.
Black diamonds.
I like the gold more than the black diamonds on you because you wear so much
black already.
I think the gold pops
up with the guy who come to your house.
Okay,
dude,
get your deal.
You reach out to her,
look at her,
shaking her head.
All I asked for all I look at him,
he looks dope.
All I want for my birthday is this and for you not to ruin my day,
you know.
Oh my God.
Tell him,
tell him your plans for birthday.
When's your birthday?
First of all,
it's April 16th.
All right.
So I told her,
she was like,
what do you do for your 40th?
I was like,
you know,
maybe go like do a track day at the racetrack,
have friends,
we'll go take labs,
you know,
like a race,
a Porsche experience,
that kind of thing.
And she was like,
oh,
okay.
Um,
can I be involved?
And I was like,
well,
I'm trying to have fun there.
But the way he phrased it,
he was like,
you know,
my friends and I are just going to the trial.
Well,
I didn't say it like that.
Like,
oh,
okay.
I was like,
well then can I can do some with you after like,
is that cool?
I was like,
well,
we're probably going to hang out after,
you know,
it's a full day.
We're going to get,
maybe get celebrate the next day with the boys.
Get something to eat,
drinks,
drinks.
It's cool.
She was going on the dms,
you know he was at his birthday party.
What do you doing,
buddy?
You guys go off for your birthday or no?
No,
I don't give,
I don't do shit either.
Mine's coming up march.
No,
this year.
It's just how really?
How old are you going to be?
35 damn.
You're young.
You're very young.
Am I really?
Sure.
All right.
You're only 40 dude.
39 39 29 you're young.
He's fuck too.
Oh yeah,
I know.
[inaudible].
Did this guy slide in your [inaudible]?
Yeah.
Can you just drive what's happening?
He's button a dude with his dick out.
Yeah.
Size.
That's a small to medium size day and that's small and how to shape and he's
dancing.
He's not doing,
we think of as a
real stiff.
It looks like yellow badges and Sin City is
it?
His dog is swinging around as he's dancing.
Oh Wow.
He just did.
A cool guy has no,
you don't
think so?
He just DM me.
Actually the guys just sitting around the world with that shaking cockatiel but
do you think he's an older man is,
oh
no,
I don't like the clothes that don't dance in spite of her song.
You old fuck.
Oh whoa.
And then its debts is only,
that's his go to.
When he runs out,
ideas goes to pluck it,
shake the
shake the,
you got it backwards.
I start
trim the hair back.
A slideshow or
you don't just get the Jack in the,
it's kind of still flowing.
Yeah.
That's what happened there.
There's some fluff in that for sure.
God is,
he gave it all to melting.
No naked Armadillo.
Original cool guy.
That's the president CEO out there.
That's not a cool man.
I'm really digging this jewelry.
You look fresh,
dude.
Yeah.
This is how you walk around all day or does she highlight want to go on stage?
It was a distraction.
That makes sense though,
but now when you shoot the special,
I just had the one out for the special black one.
No,
I had the gold one out cause for my son.
This is cool.
This dude gave you this.
Yeah,
man.
That's pretty crazy.
Did you have to do anything,
you know,
little Robert Kraft Shit.
What's up dog?
How bad you want that chain.
You want that thick like Rick Ross chain we've talked about.
Um,
I mean I'm down for any of it.
You know,
God.
He's like,
hey,
it's a,
it's birthday rings.
Do you do ring?
I don't do rings.
I remember the same.
No watches.
Watches,
necklaces.
That's the way to go.
No hard pass on the air.
It's kind of girly.
Do you know anyone?
Any dude with an airing?
Black guys can do it.
Wow.
You're right.
That's true.
They pull it off.
Well,
you have to like,
you've got that real BDE you're talking about,
you know that big Dick Energy.
Yeah.
Big Dude Energy.
Yeah,
Bro.
What about your girl?
She ended jewelry.
He had a little bit.
And Jews,
the Jews,
Jew or you're not are,
you know,
not really.
I'm not into anything.
I don't really terrible.
I'm the worst person to,
I don't care every,
anything he buys me,
I'm excited about.
I'm just not.
Did you get her that dope?
A fanny pack?
Is that a Gucci Fabulous things?
Dope big thing.
Yeah.
That was cool,
but you're not into shoes,
purses,
jewelry.
You know what I like what I was talking about this before.
I get excited going to the grocery store and just buying whatever I want.
You don't want,
I feel mostly like a baller is when my fridge is stocked with Diet Cokes.
I think it's a kid thing.
When I was a kid,
when my mom would go grocery shopping and there would be filled with all of our
favorite foods,
I'd open up,
be like,
that's right.
Yeah.
I feel good.
It's going to be a good week and I think for whatever reason it triggers that
man drinking diet cokes.
Yeah,
open it up and there's just a 24 pack and I'm just like,
fuck yeah,
I'm doing a stocked beverage fridge feels good to you if you have a variety of
that,
bro.
You drink diet drinks.
I used to drink them a lot.
I drink that Zevs via stuff a lot.
Yeah,
I fucked it was even.
Yeah.
Um,
but I,
I,
I do have a soft spot for,
especially if it's,
you know,
weeks or something have gone by and then somebody like offers a diet coke that,
but I don't buy it for the house.
Really?
Yeah,
just stopped.
Cause I'll,
I'll go through like,
it's almost like,
um,
I don't know if I'm home.
I want something like a drink.
A beverage.
Yeah.
So I'll go through like five,
six a day.
Really.
If I'm at home,
I'd like to stick to just for the most part,
water and coffee.
That's the plane,
Bro.
I know,
but I do like that as coffee.
Me Too.
Yeah.
Do you drink a lot of water?
I never drink water ever at that fucking athlete.
I'm not an athlete anymore,
but I mean when you were in,
it's up for anything though.
It's also a myth.
So if you drink lights,
eight cups of coffee,
that still counts as fluids.
It's a diuretic.
It's still a fluid.
It's a diuretic,
which means it's dehydrating.
You pushing it through,
but it's still liquid.
It's going to get kidney stones and stuff.
That part feel great right now.
Although I was getting pretty sick from drinking so much coffee.
So throwing up and stuff on sets.
Yeah.
Yup.
What did the doc alarm,
your body's just so acidic from all the coffee,
you know?
Seriously?
Yeah.
Stone up in Uber set is bad.
How much were you,
were you drinking like 1618 cups a day?
Why?
There was no part before the throwing up.
It told you that maybe that's too much.
It felt great bro.
Really?
Yeah.
Too many jobs.
And I was like a Coffee Cup.
How many jobs do we have right now?
Because this always fascinates me about you.
Well,
you have a great work ethic,
but I mean,
break it down,
break it down.
Well there's,
so my showtime stuff would blow the belt,
right?
So I do that.
And that's a days,
that's why that's a,
that's a Monday cover fights while that it's like a,
it's a fight show light,
like the beginning,
just my life.
And then I break down fights and inside information and stuff like that.
So that's Mondays.
That's right.
Yeah.
So I go from there and I shoot it in the kid with Brian Cowen on Monday.
On Monday.
This is every Monday.
Every Monday.
And then Tuesday I shoot more stuff for showtime below the belt,
which it might be a food truck diary show where it's me and a fighter and we're
at a food truck doing an interview at the food trucks and that's one.
The second is we do,
and I do king in the sting with Theo and that's Tuesdays.
Okay.
And then usually I always have standup Tuesday nights at least two sets.
Yup.
We're in a three tonight.
Where are you doing?
Comedy store and the Improv.
Wow.
So then Wednesdays I find in the kid,
when did you have a guest?
And then Thursdays I usually have another something for showtime and then stand
up at night.
Fridays I'm usually on the road or to stand up here in la.
Wow.
Hustling.
Really doing a lot of work though.
But I mean still it's not that crazy.
I think you just have a lot of different things going on too.
That's what makes it fun.
I get mad.
Do find the kid or the blind.
I die.
I hate that.
I get my captain.
The different,
how much are you road dog in it right now?
I was off the road because I shot my special in January,
so I get back on the road of March.
Wow.
Good.
Really good.
San Diego.
Yeah.
Really,
really good.
Spreckels theater in San Diego.
San Diego's a good town.
Does it have a home?
Showtime drops in May.
Congrats.
Thank you.
Have a name for it yet.
Uh,
you'd be surprised.
Yeah.
That's a good name for it.
Was going to be fun,
man.
That's awesome.
Back on the road.
Yeah.
That's exciting.
Pretty exciting.
You got to rack up those road dollars,
right?
Yeah.
I feel like we've lost all energy in our bodies.
Do you know where you know where you go first?
Ah,
I'm going to Miami.
The Miami Improv.
They redid it.
That's right.
They did.
Everyone warns me about it.
Have you been there?
You know,
but now it's more inwards in drought or uh,
I dunno,
but I didn't,
Rogan warned me about it.
Yeah,
but that was the old,
the old ones in coconut grove.
[inaudible]
be great.
I thought I know the old one.
No,
the new one's going to be good.
The new one's supposed to be good.
So I go there DC or I'm sorry,
Miami Improv.
And then uh,
we just did a Milwaukee we had in Milwaukee for this,
I think it's the third week in March.
PAPP's theater.
I've done walkie best theater.
Yeah,
it's great.
Is it awesome?
I've never done it.
It's hard to get worried about going to new markets.
It's great.
But then it's also the best green room in the business.
Really?
Yes.
So you can better than comedy works in Denver.
You can't compare,
you can't compare it because this is a theater.
So you walk in and there'll be like a Barista set up at a stand and that you're
in the greenery.
Like who's this for?
That goes for you.
And then there's a full record selection with record players.
There's old school arcade games.
Full Sofas.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's dope to Tam cause it's,
it's pretty unique.
I'm pretty excited about Milwaukee cause I'm never been.
The sock is great.
You got to go Miami,
Milwaukee and the end in March in DC.
DCM problem.
There you go.
I know.
All be on your site.
[inaudible] k.com t fat k.com.
Yes sir.
Alright.
Um,
is there anything else to show?
No Gene?
No.
What do you guys get you back on the road right now it's at the comedy store
that much.
We're on the road a lot right now on the road.
The road.
I'm there tonight.
I'm coming tonight.
Oh,
perfect.
Yeah.
Then I saw you the other night,
right?
Yes.
Yeah.
Is it,
you know what I find out by nine 30 dude,
you're smart.
It's so nice when to get in and out.
I find myself turning down a lot of stuff because too late I just don't want to
take away from my son that I know.
That's how I am.
Like you want me to do what not happening man?
There's no worries.
No.
Tonight my spots,
I have two spots there.
Eight 15 and nine 30 kids.
Perfect.
Was it 10 was it 10 30 but then know you wake up early for the kid up when my
son 5:30 AM.
Yeah,
Bro.
That's brutal,
right?
Brewed all.
Stand up at night and then wake up with the little one.
Yeah.
It's a good problem to have.
I guess it is.
We all do with kids,
man.
That's what we do.
It's how it is when you get our kids together,
dude.
There's no excuse.
Now we're fucking next to each other.
Super close to each other.
Yeah.
So in here,
who all records this whole,
and this is this whole bill.
It's just like a Rogan thing.
So we're here every week.
Uh,
Dr Drew's there.
Love doctor drew cyclones.
The way it hurts officer has the biggest hog for real.
That's the facts.
I'm going to ask me fat a stick from his boy.
Fat As deck.
Okay,
well ask him.
Ask Him.
Ask him on until track after dark.
It's a little bit of the talk,
but I'm telling you as a fan.
Oh Shit.
I gotta bring that up.
It's like a pipe.
I heard.
Really?
I guess it's like crazy big.
We got to ask a lot of things.
Making more sense.
Right.
Mike McCarthy is a,
yeah.
Yeah,
it was coast forever.
So this is the biggest day.
Oh my God.
And I was like,
he's Jack,
he's giving us you though.
You see the biceps on that dude.
Yeah,
he's,
he's in great shape.
Yeah,
it looks great.
Downplays it too.
Which would make sense.
He has the biggest Dick Energy.
Like he's just so calm and collected about it and he knows it.
He knows so much smarter and everybody is so much smarter.
I know duty blows me away when he talks.
I'm like,
what?
Like I just take sit this round out because we don't,
we don't hang around.
Regular people are like educated people.
We just hang out with a comedian douche bags all the time.
So when he talks like doctor talk,
I'm always like nothing to add.
Very cool.
Fantastic.
Like no fucking way,
man.
Do you fart a lot?
Or what else?
Sickler is here.
He starts recording in a Ryan Week.
Yup.
Good Dude.
Who else?
There's a couple other that are,
I don't want to burn them,
but there's a couple of too bad.
Didn't blurt something out because,
no,
no.
It's all good.
We'll just cut it.
We'll just edit it out.
Okay,
cool.
It's fine.
No,
but yeah,
they'll be here soon.
Santina [inaudible] going to edit this?
No,
he's not.
He's not really.
No,
because he was going to,
and he started talking about like,
you know the commute and he's just doing his own thing.
It's great.
We're total fans.
He'll be back as a guest,
but he was gonna do it here and then he started to,
you know,
it'd be like,
oh,
I'll have to do some close to my place.
I was like,
I got to come here.
It has to be here.
So,
but it's like there's no,
there's no,
we're going to edit this out,
right?
We get this stuff out.
No,
we'll leave it.
I'm really sorry.
You guys are killing it though.
So are you,
man,
I like to say thanks man.
Thanks.
Um,
yeah,
we're neighbors.
Thank you for coming over.
Yeah,
man.
I live with the big brown.
We'll do it again soon.
I hope.
Um,
love having you on dude.
Thanks so much Josh.
Come.
Yeah.
Hey Josh,
we keep me posted man.
Yeah.
He said,
well let me know when you bust that nut dude.
For sure.
We're going to have a party or something.
Right.
She screenshot it and frame your Emoji talk and I'll sign it.
That's a good idea.
We need to get these screenshots of these conversations,
especially if it actually goes down.
If he finishes,
then let's get this.
We need the evidence.
We need to see the trail.
Don't what party come party thinking.
Josh,
that's a great idea.
We're going to throw you a come party at Brendan's new house,
that sky zone so he can jump on the trampolines with hopes.
Yeah,
Bro.
What do you think?
Is that a good idea?
I'll be passing it totally down.
Alright.
Yeah.
Common party sounds great.
And compile and then zone dancing with the freak freak's like the junkies and
shit we do at Dave and busters too though.
Dave and Buster's.
Dave and bust even better Bros,
Josh and bust.
Um.
All right.
I think that's it.
All right,
man.
All right.
I'm going to leave now.
I know what's going on.
What do you mean?
Are you finding a song?
No,
I was just waiting.
Wait,
searching the web.
Oh yeah.
I'm trying to,
thanks again for giving me this.
That's very nice.
You gave me two fucking jewelry pieces.
Just revisiting Christina.
Meanwhile,
I won't fucking buy one.
I'm gonna stay.
I'm going to connect you with my guy.
Oh my God.
At least I can.
Please don't.
Please do.
Go to college.
Why the fuck are you doing this?
Why the fuck are you doing that one of your acting?
Get Real mad at me.
What the fuck are you doing?
Why are you doing this thing?
If your wife asks you to scratch your head,
does she ever ask for head scratchies and bed?
No.
Yeah,
you affectionate.
I'm a lover for sure.
I mean,
she's way more affectionate.
She's Mexican,
the shit.
So they're super affectionate,
you know,
kind of rough.
That's why he became a fighter man.
Mm.
I guess.
I mean you see all this jewelry shit,
but you don't know where it came from.
Those chains.
A change in a man.
Definitely want the swag around the house or what?
Oh my God.
Brow.
It is how it is right now.
So it is Bam,
Bam,
pow.
He was obviously,
I laid next to him in bed and then I asked for head scratches.
So good.
I hope you sleep a lot of head scratching.
It's just my currency.
It's what I love.
He's going to agree with me on that.
I barter for head scratches all that's how he's going to agree with me on this.
Anyways,
he won't give me the head scratches unless it's exactly my head is exactly what
it's worth.
Your cause in your arm gets tired.
Your forum just it get tired.
He's late.
I'm laying down,
we're laying down.
He can't bend his elbow like this.
If you want to lay here,
you're laying in bed like,
look,
you're laying down watching TV.
Like I'm going to go to bed and she asks for head scratch.
You Go.
Don't go to Ben Taub,
man.
How about you make it convenient like you,
you're want the thing.
So could you be where my hand naturally lazy.
She's all like over here.
I'm like,
well,
can I have to go like this?
So I'm like,
how about you just lay your head over here?
So all I did was I just pushed her head and then scratch there.
It's easier for you,
works for you.
Do you hear what he said?
He pushed my head last night like I was a dog on the bed.
Like it over there.
That's a little fucked up.
They could've asked,
but I'm with him making it more right.
But he could have asked him about,
it was kind of rude to just push your head like you guys get a fight after that.
No,
I don't find it on that.
I pick,
I pick my battles.
I bust his chops in a joking.
I just don't seem like you fight very much.
I love him.
You have to understand.
Oh,
you'd have to.
I Adore Thompson Sigora like a door.
He really can do no wrong in my eyes,
which is probably,
I don't know the secret.
I adore you to no,
but I actively,
I,
I make sure he has treats in the house.
Treats.
Yeah.
I feed him.
I pet him.
I love him.
I love you.
I do the same time.
I know you take care of me.
It's,
and it's all scratchy.
So I go,
this is uncomfortable.
Like you're pushed my hand.
I didn't look that,
that is not what I did not dismiss it.
We'll do it.
Do it.
How you did it last night.
Okay,
here's your head.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but you pushed my head.
I kept scratching,
kept scratching and then one time Brendan,
I was laying down sleeping and he comes in,
I'm,
I'm asleep.
He comes in and I'm,
my head's on the pillow and then he starts fluffing his pillow,
my pillow
and you were sleeping.
But here's,
here's what's up.
Here's the truth.
Here's the thing.
I didn't know she was in bed.
That's when that happened.
Children,
it was just the two of us.
And that's when that happened.
I don't know where you were.
Two bedroom apartment at that point.
You know that that's the story.
You were covered up and I didn't realize you were in bed.
That's why I walked up to my pillow and I was like,
this isn't fluff and I smashed the hell out of it.
It was smashing that you really got to get into.
I was pounding it and then you were like,
what's going on?
I was like,
Oh shit.
I didn't know you were in here.
That's what,
that's what I look how you leave out.
Like the most key point of that story,
which was that I definitely didn't know you were asleep in bed.
Yeah.
What's the maddest you've ever got at Tom?
Oh God.
Just been get together for a hot second.
Yeah.
Let me think on it.
I don't,
he doesn't do a lot to infuriate me.
He doesn't do a lot of me.
I'm telling you dude,
like have been close to go their separate ways.
No,
never.
Never.
I mean,
I haven't have you.
This is the reason why he doesn't listen to me.
Women are mother fucking hate carts.
There's that about this.
I've stuff that irritates me like this.
Like when he's on his pushy button,
Nautilus and never listening to me like I at least five times a day,
I have to be like,
are you listening to me?
Are you listening to me?
It's impossible.
Well,
the tax and list of a cell,
it's hard to tell a story.
Still.
Dylan's on,
they're texting.
They're like,
uh Huh.
Uh Huh.
Yeah.
Listening.
Well that's up on my Instagram.
Hey guys,
I'm on a roll today because women are fucking stupid.
There you go.
That's what I deal with.
What about you and your lady?
What do you think drives her crazy about you?
Tons of stuff.
She has OCD and she's like real clean.
Oh,
just don't give a fuck.
I'm too busy conquering other stuffs.
I don't know if there's a math or something like that.
I'll get to it.
Yeah.
You know,
like it's not a priority for me.
We're both messy,
so that's a blessing.
So then it's,
since you're both messy,
you pay someone to clean it up.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Right.
And we always have.
Yeah.
So worth it.
No,
no fights about other shit to do.
Waste of time.
It's not that important.
Yeah.
Not that important.
What else do I do that pisses you off?
Mostly not,
not listening.
God.
The device.
The constant phone looking like you're and then,
yeah.
Fun.
Yeah.
I think most people are dope.
It's the modern stope.
Everybody's addicted.
The most disciplined people I know are addicted to it.
I try to do things now though,
where I will,
uh,
you know,
if I'll go and like play room with my kid,
I'll leave it on the stairs.
Oh cool.
That's not even on me.
Usually Saturdays and Sundays I'll just,
I leave my phone upstairs.
I don't even touch my feet.
That's a great idea.
I'll,
if I have like a show or something the following week,
I'll post that morning.
I just,
I don't even touch it and most of my friends know that if they want to get ahold
of me up not signing on Sunday,
I won't be around my family like that.
Yeah,
I like that.
Did you know that there's a feature that you can see how long,
how much screen time you've had.
I shouldn't pops up now.
Like you're down 30% from last week.
You only spent four hours and 30 minutes a day.
That's a lie.
Fuck yeah,
but does that,
but I'm thinking they're counting podcasts I listen to when I drive down
everything.
I Dunno.
Is it,
are they,
I don't know.
I don't know how they do it.
How it calculates,
scratch.
Horrifying.
Have you seen that?
Oh yeah.
And you're like,
whoa.
It'll make you feel like a piece of shit.
Yeah.
Or when I'm like trying to do this and my son's like,
Daddy,
I'm like,
probably get this to,
you know,
but it's just business.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
I don't handle it because he doesn't know it's a business.
He's probably like,
all these phones more important than whatever I'm doing.
Look,
he just did it right now.
Jesus.
And it's always there.
It's always urgent.
There's always a reason.
But then she also always doesn't get it.
But like I said,
there's a reason for,
there's always a reason.
There's always a reason.
But here's deal man,
is that people now it's always business,
but the reason it's always urgent that they can get ahold of,
you know,
24 seven problem.
And if you,
if you let them get ahold of you instantaneously,
24 seven I want that message to come in.
Right.
I know I want to respond to it.
Okay.
You're waiting for an important message.
I'm communicating with him so it's not that important.
Well it's or are you saying please wrap,
get shoved the fuck out and talk about this song man.
Like oh he's traveling and my Hassan but then like,
but then this is what happens to it with,
with your touring,
you know what I'm saying?
Like cause for you at the take turns with you also don't,
don't,
you're not as on top of it as I am business wise.
The of course like you'll just be like,
that's fine.
But that's what I'm saying.
So then you're giving me a hard time about the gate.
Can't both be the business.
Not all the time.
One of us has to watch the kids and take care of the kids,
but even right now it's like that's it.
Like I'm not going to ignore that.
Right.
They say you can only have one headshot in the household,
but you guys were the only couple of that's figured it out.
I never heard that.
I've never heard that number and that I don't know.
But I do think that I,
I mean right now I've got a baby and a toddler,
so they're my priority.
So you would,
he's back on the touring.
He back on a lot of shit so that they're the priority.
Definitely 100% when you were to go full throttle and you would prefer that.
I just don't pick up.
No,
no,
no.
All I'm saying is I honestly don't care right now,
but I'm saying if we're at dinner and we're all sitting around eating that,
yeah.
Like it takes real discipline,
man to do it again.
The most disciplined people I know struggle with it.
So I'm like,
this is some fucking addictive stuff,
man.
It is.
These people are suffering from it
or just when we're with the kids.
I think that's what bothers me.
What?
Okay.
You feel like that's a real issue or if the kid asking me right now,
I said no,
the only time it bothers me is when one with the kids cause then that's the
message they get that they're not as important as your text message was.
Look,
you have a phone problem Tom.
Yeah,
we figured this out.
I feel like doctor drew right now.
I helped him with his fucking come emojis and ship advice on doctors.
I just heard you on Dr drafter dark.
You were saying how you liked that Ari encourages you to put your phone down
more.
I do but you're not already and you also,
you're also completely unreasonable because you were in charge of my phone.
There would be so much shit that slips through the cracks and doesn't get done.
I'm on top of stuff.
I take care of business,
but then you still are someone who is like,
God,
you're on your phone.
Yes,
a handling business,
but not hire someone to do this.
Hire someone,
agent or manager or sometimes I'm communicating with them.
I know.
It's like,
why do I have your foot?
Why?
Why have a middle man when I'm doing it anyways?
Yeah,
of course.
Man.
I'm a fucking beast though.
It's a beast.
Yeah.
I don't know the answer.
There's a lot of people that I have to communicate with on a regular a lot.
Yeah.
I mean here there's people that communicate with all the time.
Then yeah,
there's business people.
Agents May,
I also think that your,
your condition where you feel like you have to respond to the email,
you have to respond to the text.
You know?
That's true.
You don't have to respond not to do shit.
No,
but respond asap or are you going to lose that show?
Are you going to lose this or that?
No.
No,
but there are things that like you also realize,
if I don't respond to this,
I'm not going to remember to do this.
Oh,
you're so you're worried if you don't
listen to me.
I'm not saying that you don't,
you shouldn't respond to your business stuff.
I'm just saying there should be certain boundaries,
right?
Like I don't know when,
when you're home with the family,
maybe the phone isn't the main priority at seven o'clock more six c just have
boundaries and it protects you and gives you a chance to have a rest.
Good.
It also feels so good when I leave my phone somewhere,
I'm gone the entire day.
I'm like,
oh,
thank God man.
No,
I agree.
I've already does.
Where it has a flip phone.
There's a social media.
I wish,
man,
now I forgotten to healthy is healthy at the house and been out entire day,
which is nice.
You don't feel tied down by it.
No,
but I mean I'd leave it charging in rooms all the time,
you know,
like in the attic right now.
But we'll figure it out.
Yeah.
Everyone has a problem.
I mean,
I'm sure if you brought my girl and then she said the exact same thing,
the exact same Ms.
Dot.
Yeah.
But I'm also,
I mean,
more people are trying to reach me then,
you know,
look,
I know,
hey,
I'm grateful that you handle all the business stuff you do,
gene.
You know that,
you know,
I know know.
Come on.
Shamaz she'd just seen the check I sent today.
Okay.
So with a breakthrough today,
we had a breakthrough brand did come back so that we can do more of a really
nice,
he listens,
he listens to you.
We need your jewelry contact.
Yeah,
I got Ya.
Yeah.
Birthday's in April.
Yeah,
no more fam.
Thanks Bro.
All right.
Uh,
thank you again,
Brendan.
Shop
pretty
okay.
[inaudible]
thank you.
Fun Fun.
Are you
driving?